Renault Pierou, bonsoir. Bonsoir
professeur Renault Pierou. Nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle Sinkerview. Nous sommes en
direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succintement ?
Donc je suis donc professeur à Sorbon
Université à la faculté de santé, on dit
plus faculté de médecine, on dit faculté
de santé de Sorbonne université, chef de
service à la Pitié Salpétrière et en
fait spécialiste des épidémies que
j'ai côtoyé à la fois comme clinicien,
pédiatre infecteiologue au départ puis
comme
microbiologiste, puis en intervenant sur
le terrain sur différentes grandes
épidémies, beaucoup les épidémies de
choléra mais pas que. Un peu de peste
aussi. Et euh depuis quelques années,
ben j'essaie de comprendre un peu plus
en profondeur. Et donc je me suis plongé
ces derniers temps, ces dernières années
dans le l'histoire des épidémies et je
viens d'écrire un livre qui s'appelle
Sapiens et les microbes, les épidémies
d'autrefois et qui permettent de
probablement de mieux comprendre ce qui
se passe actuellement parce que ça donne
de la profondeur. Alors aujourd'hui, on
va parler naissance des pandémies, vari
pilis, tuberculose, choléra, grippe
espagnole, sida, les écatombes
microbiennes et la conquête des
Amériques, de l'Australie, de l'Océanie,
les épidémies de l'histoire des
États-Unis, les biais cognitifs, conflit
d'intérêt et paroles scientifiques, la
longévité des dogmes en médecine, les
deux découvertes biologiques qui ont
changé le monde, les microbes et l'ADN,
le rôle de la médecine dans la
colonisation de l'Afrique, les récits
d'épidémie, la peste antonine, la peste
de Marseille, le choléra Haïti,
l'origine du sida, la variation, la
vaccination et les mouvements antivax et
l'origine du Covid histoire de mettre la
cerise sur le gâteau. Professeur, on
commence par la naissance des pandémies.
D'accord. Vaste programme quand même.
Alors, on va on va y aller. La naissance
des pandémies. Pourquoi c'est
intéressant ? parce que justement c'est
un moyen de comprendre pourquoi des
pandémies arrivent et de comprendre
peut-être pourquoi certaines pandémies
récentes sont
arrivées en ayant regardé ce qui s'est
passé dans le passé. Il y a pas toujours
eu des pandémies.
Le l'homme préhistorique était avait un
mode de vie qui était pas très propice
aux pandémies parce que euh pour que les
microbes se diffusent de d'un groupe à
l'autre, ça devait prendre beaucoup de
temps et ça ne pouvait pas marcher. Donc
les premières pandémies viennent avec,
on va dire les empires, en tout cas les
cités et des regroupements de population
suffisants pour que pour que ça puisse
fonctionner.
Et donc l'Empire romain va se retrouver
finalement le le premier empire pour
lequel on a une pandémie bien
analysé. C'est au autour de 165 après
Jésus-Christ. C'est du temps d'un
médecin qui s'appelle Galen qui est un
médecin grec mais qui travaille à Rome.
Et on va avoir ce qu'on appelle la
pestantonine. Et la première chose c'est
peut-être une des premières raisons de
la création des pandémies de l'arrivée
des pandémies. C'est justement ces
empires avec le microbe. Là, c'est un
virus, le virus probablement le virus de
la variole qui va arriver depuis
l'Égypte et puis rentrer dans le dans
l'Empire romain pour euh aller vers Rome
et ensuite rayonner autour. Alors, c'est
intéressant parce que en fait jus même
le Covid a fonctionné comme ça,
c'est-à-dire euh ça part d'un endroit et
puis ça va vers les hubs, vers le centre
de l'Empire. Alors là, ce sera on
pourrait dire l'Empire d'Occident avec
les grandes villes européennes et puis
ensuite les New York et les grandes
villes américaine. Donc ce trajet des
pandémies vers l'intérieur en fait date
depuis le début. Il faut des
concentrations de population et c'est
comme ça que ça se passe. Ça va viser
essentiellement la capitale. Après euh
donc premier mécanisme finalement euh si
on avance un peu, on va on va arriver
aux pandémies de peste. Il y en a une à
la fin du euh à la fin de de l'antiquité
au 6e siècle qui va être la peste de
Justinien du temps de l'empereur
Justinien. Alors, j'ai passé quelques
pandémies mais celle-là est quand même
intéressante. Et là aussi, elle va de
toute façon arriver de l'extérieur,
aller vers la capitale. Mais la
capitale, c'est plus Rome à ce
moment-là, c'est euh c'est l'Empire
byzantin. C'est la ville qu'on va
appeler ensuite
Constantinople, même elle qui s'appelle
déjà Constantinople de l'empereur
Constantin. Et là, pareil, c'est une
pandémie qui va arriver mais qui va
arriver, qui va être favorisée par un
nouvel élément, c'est l'invasion. du
pourtour méditerranéen par les rats et
par les rats noirs parce que il y a du
commerce de de grain, il y a des
bateaux, il y a des greniers et
finalement le rat noir qui vient d'Asie
va pouvoir s'installer là et qui porte
la puce. Alors le rat lui-même n'est pas
le transmetteur, c'est une victime de la
peste mais le vecteur de la peste c'est
la puce du rat. Tant qu'il y avait pas
de grande quantité de rat noir, bah il y
avait pas de diffusion de des pandémies
de de pandémie de peste. À partir du
moment où il est là, le système a
fonctionné différemment, la société
fonctionnait différemment et faisait le
lit de la
peste. Autre exemple qui marche
complètement différemment, c'est la
syphilis. Là, on est à une période qui
est une période de mondialisation.
Alors, il y a eu la peste noire avant,
mais c'est finalement même mécanisme. La
peste arrive, le rat noir et cetera. Ça
c'est au 14e siècle. Et puis euh pas si
longtemps après, la fin du 15e siècle,
Christophe Colomb va découvrir ce qui
croit être des des îles proches des
Indes ou du
Japon et qui euh ce serait bien de
d'enlever
leoui la même
chose. On continue continue. Christophe
Colom
va aller donc sur l'île qui va appeler
Espagnola, qui maintenant fait Haïti et
saint et Saint-Domingue, la République
dominicaine.
Et il revient, c'est navigateur revient
et c'est probablement comme ça qu'ils
amènent la syphilis. Et la syphilie,
c'est une maladie catastrophique à ce
moment-là, vraiment horrible en terme de
douleur, en terme de de lésion, lésion
cutanée, des des ulcères, des enfin
c'est vraiment transmission de la
syphilis, mode de transmission sexuel,
c'est une c'est une maladie sexuellement
transmissible, une infection
sexuellement transmissible mais là
vraiment calamiteuse qui va toucher les
rois François I qui va toucher même les
papes. Donc bon, on voit comment ils
l'ont attrapé quand même hein, ils ont
pas fait différemment des autres et qui
va finalement être la première vraie
pandémie qui va toucher à partir des
Amériques et toucher l'Europe, l'Asie,
l'Afrique, donc toucher l'ensemble des
continents y compris l'Océanie un peu
plus tard.
Donc là, c'est on est allé chercher un
microbe qui existait et on l'amène sur
un territoire où il était pas connu.
L'inverse va se faire mais on en
reparlera avec la variole dans les dans
les Amériques et les dégâts que ça fait
mais on en parlera un peu plus tard.
Autre mécanisme, ben c'est les pandémies
qui surviennent au 19e siècle. Là on va
avoir deux deux maladies qui vont
dominer. C'est d'un côté la tuberculose
qui va prendre une une ampleur
considérable. et de l'autre le choléra
qui va la trouille à tout le
monde. La peur bleue ça vient du le mot
peur bleu vient du choléra. Et ça c'est
lié à des grandes villes qui prennent un
essort considérable. Londres qui va
avoir plus d'un million d'habitants ou
Paris qui sera peut-être plutôt un peu
plus petit mais quand même relativement
grand qui attiendra le million mais un
peu plus tard. et les faubourgs de ces
grandes villes. Énormément de gens qui
viennent de la campagne qui vivent dans
des conditions totalement indécentes. Il
y a un très beau texte de Victor Hugo
qui décrit la le la vie dans les caves
de l'île. Vous cherchez les caves de
Lille sur internet et vous trouverez ça.
Et c'est vraiment euh très révélateur
des conditions de vie pour et pourquoi
on va retrouver la tuberculose qui va
tuer peut-être 20 % de la population de
ces villes à ce moment-là.
la tuberculose et puis le choléra qui
tue un peu moins de monde mais de
manière tellement spectaculaire sous la
forme d'épidémie tellement violente que
ça fout la trouille à tout le monde. Le
choléra lui c'est parce que l'apport en
eau potable dans ces villes est pas du
tout assuré. Les compagnies qui
distribuent l'eau, pompent l'eau dans la
tamise à Londres ou dans la scène à
Paris, la redonne à boire aux gens et
s'il y a évidemment contamination par
l'eau d'égût, on va avoir une
transmission de du choléra par cette
manière-là. On avance encore. On a la
grippe espagnole là. on est en pleine
guerre et c'est vraiment la gestion de
d'une pandémie de grippe mais pas si
grave que ça au
début mais c'est pendant la guerre que
une après une première vague une
deuxième vague arrive mais alors qui est
d'une gravité terrible avec une grippe
qui est devenue beaucoup plus létale,
beaucoup plus mortelle et en fait ça se
passe dans des camps d'entraînement ou
dans les trajets des des militaires
depuis les États-Unis jusqu'à l'Europe
et vice-versa. Et là, on a une explosion
de forme extrêmement grave qui en plus
sont dispatché à droite à gauche sans
aucune considération pour le pour le
danger. Et là, on a une une pandémie qui
se met en place et qui va être qui va
tuer peut-être des dizaines de millions
de personnes, peut-être 50 millions,
peut-être même plus de personnes qui
représentent peut-être 2 à 5 % de la
population de
l'époque. Et puis donc encore un autre
mécanisme. C'est ça je voudrais pour ça
cette énumération, c'est pour comprendre
ces mécanismes. Le sida, ben le sida, on
le voit en début des années 80 et le
sida, il démarre avant la pandémie de
grippe espagnole. Il démarre en 1916, en
1915 ou en 1916. Maintenant, on a à peu
près dat le le l'origine du virus. C'est
un virus de chimpanzés, des chimpanzés
qui vivaient dans la forêt du sud-est du
Cameroun. Et qu'est-ce qui se passe à
cette à cette époque-là ? Ben, c'est la
Première Guerre mondiale. Le Cameroun,
il est allemand et ben les Anglais, les
Français et les Belges vont chasser les
Allemands du Cameroun. Alors euh quand
je dis les Anglais, les Français et les
Belges, les officiers, oui, les soldats
eux c'est des tirailleurs africains qui
viennent de différentes parties de de
l'Afrique dont une colonne qui vient de
Léopold qui euh en fait euh est devenue
Kinshasa. En face, il y a Brazaville.
Donc des Français et des Belges qui
remontent les le Congo, la le fleuve
Congo, puis ensuite une rivière, la
rivière sanga et qui vont combattre les
Allemands quelque part dans cette forêt
où se trouvent ces chimpanzés qui ont un
virus qui est le l'ancêtre du virus du
sida, celui qui a donné la pandémie
parce qu'il a plusieurs virus achivés
mais il y en a un qui a vraiment donné
une pandémie, c'est HIV1 M comme main
major le plus important. Et là, ils vont
rester pendant plus d'un an à barbeuter
dans la forêt primaire. C'est pas mal
inondé et mal ravitaillé. Bah, il faut
qu'il se débrouille. Et et on peut tout
à fait imaginer que les premiers les
premières personnes à attraper ce virus,
c'est en dép en tuant en dépessant un
champané. Des centaines de soldats avec
des fusils ayant besoin de manger tuent
des chimpanzés. logique. Et puis ensuite
quand ils reviennent parce que la chose
étonnante c'était comment on pouvait
arriver du Cameroun à Léopoleville à
Kinshasa. C'est simplement que c'était
les mêmes soldats qui étaient là dans le
Cameroun qui sont revenus à Léopoleville
et là c'est une ville où les beaucoup de
personnes viennent travailler sans les
familles, beaucoup de prostitution,
beaucoup de traitements médicaux avec
des des injections et là on habitue
petit à petit le virus du sida à se
transmettre d'homme à homme pour devenir
pandémique. Bon s'en aperçoit 60 ans
après quand on dit voilà les comment les
pandémies peuvent démarrer chaque fois
avec quelque chose de nouveau. Quand on
dit traitement par injection,
c'est-à-dire qu'il y avait pas les
conditions sanitaires pour désinfecter
le matériel, que c'était les les
seringues à de l'époque réutilisable
mais pas très bien nettoyé. C'est ça. Ça
a duré assez longtemps. C'est ça. Oui,
c'est euh on va dire pas nettoyé ou
vraiment nettoyé de manière non
efficace. Alors, on en a la on en a la
certitude parce que d'abord il y a il y
a pas que le sida qui a démarré comme
ça. On a des épidémies d'hépatite C.
au Cameroun justement. Et donc
l'hépatite C, on la voit bien et on voit
le à quel moment ça ça a eu lieu parce
que les gens restent porteurs pendant
des décennies. Donc en faisant une
sérologie, en regardant l'âge des
personnes et les tranches d'âge, on peut
savoir à quel moment ça a émergé. Donc
ça c'est une chose qu'on a vu. Ça a
aussi existait d'ailleurs une très
grosse épidémie d'hépatite C avec des
traitements injectables en Égypte pour
un le traitement d'une maladie qui
s'appelle la bilarsiose. Au Cameroun,
c'est plutôt pour traiter la maladie du
sommeil ou le paludisme. À Kinshasa,
c'est le paludisme, les maladies
sexuellement transmissibles. Mais on a
déjà ça. Et on a aussi une autre alors
ça a pas donné une pandémie mais une
autre épidémie, c'est l'épidémie
d'Ébola. La première épidémie d'Ébola en
1976, elle a lieu dans un une petite
ville complètement au nord de la
République démocratique du Congo, Zaï à
l'époque, qui s'appelle Yambouuku. Et à
l'hôpital de Yambou qui est un hôpital
qui fait à peu près 120 lits, il y a
cinq
seringues pour toute la population donc
enfin et donc elle est utilisée sans
évidemment être nettoyée. Et là on a une
première grosse épidémie d'ébola avec
plusieurs centaines de morts liées
simplement à la transmission par la par
les seringues. Donc on a ces mécanismes
qui permettent au virus de profiter mais
ces mécanismes, ils existent que
maintenant. Alors, je dis ça parce que
on entend souvent dire "Oui, les euh les
épidémies, les pandémies, ça a toujours
été de telle manière, par exemple, ça a
toujours été une
zoon alors ça va rester une zooose."
C'est un non sens parce que les
mécanismes eux, ils vont changer au fur
et à mesure que nos sociétés évoluent,
les mécanismes des pandémies changent.
Et donc, peut-être que pour le Covid, on
y viendra plus tard, mais peut-être que
pour le Covid, faut chercher des
mécanismes nouveaux. Sinon, pourquoi il
n'apparaît que maintenant ? Voilà les
les choses qu'on peut se poser comme
question. Donc sur les pandémies, le
message c'est euh c'est lié complètement
à nos sociétés et c'est lié à notre
manière de vivre, notre organisation. Et
comme celle-ci, elle change d'un moment
à l'autre de l'histoire, on va avoir des
pandémies qui changent d'un moment à
l'autre de l'histoire. Ah, avant de
parler des États-Unis, de l'Océanie et
tout ça et des Indiens et j'en passé des
meilleurs de l'Amérique du Sud, juste
une question euh basique. Le Covid-19,
c'est le pangolin ou c'est pas le
pangolin ? Bon, ça bon, c'est que c'est
pas le pangolin, ça c'est clair.
Euh je crois que le pangolin a servi un
petit peu à faire
diversion. Oui, on va dire comme ça.
On un peu plus tard. On en parlera plus
tard mais je réponds c'est pas le
pangolin ça on en a la certitude. Ce
qu'on sait aussi c'est qu'on a trouvé
aucun réservoir animal puisqu'on dit que
le Covid c'est une
zonose. Alors bien sûr que à l'origine
il y a les chauves-souris. Chaouris, ça
tout le monde il y a qu'ensisse
là-dessus. Mais comment des
chauves-souris du sud de la Chine ou du
nord du Laos euh il arrive dans une
ville euh à peu près la la taille de
Paris mais plus moderne quand même.
Ou comment ça arrive là ? Il y a quand
même 1500 km. Les
chauves-souris, il y en a pas à Bouran.
Enfin ces chauves-souris là en
particulier elles ne sont pas vendues au
marché. le pangola non plus et surtout
on a trouvé aucun réservoir
intermédiaire. On s'est dit bon, il y a
un animal qui l'a amené.
On a une
hypothèse que un réservoir comme le
chien Vivérin aurait pu jouer un rôle
mais ça n'est resté en 5 ans au stade
d'hypothèse. Il y a pas eu le moindre
embryon de d'explication de preuves de
contamination d'un animal sauvage avant
les premiers cas trouvés chez l'homme.
Après, il y a eu des animaux sauvages
touchés. le ser le voilà des sers vidé
pour les animaux sauvages des sers vidé
aux États-Unis effectivement donc en
fait contaminé par l'homme et le vison
Danemarque donc là ils sont pas sauvages
parce que c'est c'est des élevages avec
donc on peut l'homme est tout à fait
capable de transmettre chat le tigre
dans les eaux le les chats les tigres et
les hamsters aussi voilà on a fait à peu
près le le tour mais ça n'est on a pour
une zonose ce serait la première zoon
Bonos sans animal en tout cas à
l'origine reviendra. L'homme est un
animal.
Oui, c'est vrai. C'est un grand singe.
Revenons à pour pouvoir parler du Covid,
il faut qu'on fasse l'historicité des
pandémies. comment mais c'est déjà un
premier un premier une première leçon de
voir comment les pandémies ont émergé et
comment finalement à chaque fois on a
une nouvelle explication, une nouvelle
cause, quelque chose qui a changé sinon
elle aurait déjà eu lieu.
On fait Amérique du Nord, Amérique du
Sud ou historiquement ce qu'il y a le
plus ancien ou historiquement on
commence par l'Amérique du Sud.
L'Amérique du Sud. Alors en fait si on
veut on va peut-être si on veut parler
de la conquête des euh des Amériques,
faut commencer par Christophe Colomb,
faut commencer par les Caraïbes puisque
Christophe Colomb, il arrive au Bahamas
à Cuba. Euh donc il va voir les les
populations locales, son les Tain Inos
et finalement il s'installe enfin il
installe sa troupe un certain temps
euh au nord d'Haïti actuellement. Euh
donc sur l'île d'Hispagnola, il va
l'appeler comme ça, qui s'appellera plus
tard Saint-Domingue et qui maintenant
est Haïti plus la République
dominicaine. Euh il a une petite
centaine de de personnes avec lui, hein.
Une caravelle, une caraque et deux
caravelles. Euh la Caraque, c'est la
Santa Maria. ils réussissent à l'échouer
et donc elle peut pas repartir. Ils vont
récupérer le bois pour faire un fortin
et il laisse comme ça une petite
quarantaine de ses compagnons sur place
et il rentre euh en en Espagne avec les
deux autres avec les les deux deux
autres bateaux et puis c'est là que
probablement donc il ramène la syphilis
vers l'Espagne. Il y a vraiment des
éléments assez forts pour penser que ça
s'est passé comme ça. Les 40 qui sont
restés sur place, ils se
sont disputés, engatés avec la
population locale. Quand Christophe
Colombe revient la fois d'après, il y a
plus personne. Bon, alors il est fâché,
il revient avec du monde et là ça
commence un peu être la les tueries et
les guerres et on va voir finalement sur
une période de de quelques générations,
de quelques dizaines d'années seulement
un effondrement de la population Taïos
qui va mourir à cause de ces guerres,
qui va mourir à cause du servage où les
populations sont auquel les populations
sont soumises. Les hommes vont essayer
d'extraire de l'or dans des
conditions calamiteuses. Les femmes sont
obligées de faire les travaux des
champs. Elles elles ont plus assez à
manger, il y a plus de naissance.
Système immunitaire qui collapse parce
que comme Oui, bien sûr. Et finalement
même les même les colons eux-mêmes, les
les Espagnols vont souffrir de la fin
dans un endroit où il y avait plusieurs
centaines de milliers de personnes qui
vivaient. Mais là plus personne ne
cultive correctement et cetera et on a
un effondrement et ça va être le premier
et non et loin d'être le dernier
évidemment il des maladies on a du mal à
les à les situer. semble qu'il y a eu
une première épidémie de vari au tout
début de du 16e siècle et puis ben
puisqu'il y a un effondrement, ben il là
on va commencer à faire venir des
esclaves depuis l'Afrique, depuis les
ports, les comptoirs portugais qui sont
sur la côte africaine. Parce que les
Espagnols et les Portugais sont entendu
avec le pape.
Ils ont un
traité traité de tordéas qui sépare à
peu près
la moitié pour les Portugais. La moitié
pour les Portugais, c'est l'Afrique et
en gros l'Oindien qui ne connaissent pas
encore très bien. Et la moitié pour les
Espagnol, ce sont les Amériques, sauf le
Brésil parce que la moitié coupe à peu
près à ce niveau-là et ça va jusque euh
jusque l'autre bout du Pacifique. Et
donc ils sont ils sont dit "Bah, on est
les propriétaires de tout ça." Bon, il y
a beaucoup de monde à ce moment-là. Il y
a beaucoup plus de monde au Mexique par
exemple. L'Empire aste on va dire c'est
20, c'est peut-être 25 millions. Enfin,
on c'est un ordre de grandeur. On ne
peut pas savoir. Ça peut être 30 ou un
petit peu moins. Euh l'Espagne c'est 9
millions et c'est de tous ces ces pays.
Ensuite, il va il y aura l'Angleterre
avec l'Angleterre qui fait 2 millions
d'habitants à l'époque et puis le
Portugal c'est 1 million. Donc c'est des
petites nations, c'est pas les nations
qui dominent. L'Empire ottoman est
beaucoup plus puissant déjà que
l'Espagne ou ou le Portugal. Et pourtant
c'est comme c'est des nations qui sont
sur la façade atlantique, ils vont
arriver. Et ce qui va
déterminer la conquête de l'Amérique,
c'est vraiment une succession
d'épidémie. Alors, on va prendre
l'exemple des astèques parce que les
pauvres ce qu'ils ont pris c'est donc on
est on avance un peu. Christophe Colombe
c'est 1492.
Là, c'est Cortes qui arrive en
1519 euh qui débarque près de près de
Canckoun, qui débarque dans le Yukatan
sur le Mexique et qui va longer la côte,
arriver vers ce qui est maintenant
Vercru et ensuite rentrer à l'intérieur
pour aller ce qui est maintenant Mexico
qui est Tenostitlan, une énorme cité
lacustre, bien plus riche, bien plus
puissante que n'importe quel cité
espagnole de l'époque. Et là, c'est les
aste qui sont au pouvoir et qui font
régner un peu la terreur sur les cités
environnantes. L'ensemble faisant
peut-être 20 millions de personnes, des
armées importantes. D'accord, ils ont
pas de cavalerie, d'accord, ils ont pas
de d'armes à feu,
mais quand même, c'est bon, quand on
voit arriver des dizaines de milliers de
de soldats à steak qui viennent nous qui
veulent taper dessus, enfin, c'est pas
forcément facile. D'ailleurs, malgré
toute la l'intelligence stratégique
d'Hernan Cortez qui arrive jusqu'à Teno
Titlan, qui arrive à se faire inviter,
qui prend l'empereur en otage euh pour
s'assurer une certaine paix, ça finit
par tourner au vinaigre et euh ils
essayent de s'enfuir. C'est on est en en
juin 1520, c'est la nôtre c'est triste
et ils essayent de partir sur des pont
avec leurs chevaux et tout ça. Ils se
font repérés et en gros la moitié les
deux tiers des espagnols meurent là et
le reste enfin il se retrouve dans la
c'est une cité lacus il se trouve au
fond du lac le reste est en fuite.
Franchement ils sont très mal barrés
l'armée maintenant ils sont plus du tout
envie de les inviter. Ils veulent s' en
finir avec eux ils sont poursuivis. Et
c'est là que la variole arrive. Elle est
arrivée quelques mois plus tôt à
Veracruz. Elle arrive maintenant à
Tenitlan au cœur du Mexique et cette
variole a été d'ailleurs amenée par un
esclave
de transmission de la variole
respiratoire
essentiellement c'est une c'est une
maladie qui se traduisait qui a été
éradiquée. C'est la seule grande maladie
qui a été éradiquée qui donnait une
éruption très importante. Une mortalité
ça dépend des moments mais qui pouvait
aller et là dans ce contexte là plutôt à
20 30 %.
Et donc une maladie où les gens
restaient malades pendant des mois et
des mois. Enfin, c'était c'était
vraiment violent avec des une éruption,
des
saignement. Bref, un truc qui est loin
d'être facile. Certains guérissaient
mais avec une atteinte de la cornée qui
faisait qu'il devenait aveugle. Donc ça
fait quand même c'est difficile ensuite
pour lancer ses lances sur les les
espagnols. Oui. Et puis en plus euh les
Espagnols eux n'avaient rien. Logique
parce que la variole elle existait en
Europe. Elle était elle était arrivée
depuis quelques siècles avec les les
guerres d'ailleurs entre les Arabes et
les Sarasins et les Européens. Et donc
la variole était était devenue une
maladie infantile. Il y en avait
tellement que ben les enfants l'
attrapai. Il survivaient surviv ceux qui
survivaient bah devenaient adultes et
pouvaient devenir conquistador. Et ceux
qui étaient morts bah de toute façon les
Indiens les Amérindiens les voyaient
pas. Ils étaient ils étaient morts en
Europe avant et personne n'avait le
moindre la moindre idée que cette
maladie pouvait toucher les espagnols.
Et donc c'est tout d'un coup on voit ces
soldats ces ces conquistadors qui sont
en pleine épidémie qui sont en pleine
forme et tout le monde aussi a 20 30 %
de la population qui meurt mais
quasiment tout le monde a attrapé la
maladie donc tout le monde est au tapis
et là il y a des renversements
d'alliance et Cortez finit par
prendreitlan et se débarrasser
descidémie va se poursuivre le long de
la côte et arriver jusqu'à l'empire un
cas et quand Pizaro un autre espagnol
arrive au niveau de de Cousco et de la
capitale et ben en fait il a plus qu'à
récupérer les trucs. Lui aussi va
prendre en otage l'empereur mais on est
sur une guerre de succession et
finalement il va ils vont jouer avec ça
pour prendre le pouvoir. Comment il
s'appelait le gars ? C'était Atawalpac
non c'était l'autre Atawalpa. Oui, c'est
ça. Il y avait Wascar et Atawalpa et il
se faisait la guerre parce que
l'empereur puis son fils aîné était déjà
mort et donc il
fallait les deux qui étaient pas les
héritiers légitimes ni l'un ni l'autre
ben sont dit ben c'est moi, c'est moi.
Mais ils se sont fait la guerre et donc
les Pissaro a profité de des
circonstances. Alors lui, ça lui a pas
porté tellement, ça l'a pas beaucoup
aidé parce qu'il était tellement
violent, tellement sanguinaire que c'est
finalement les Espagnol qui l'ont oxy
parce que il était vraiment gênant dans
sa manière de faire et ça mettait tout
le monde en danger. Mais le l'Empire in
cas est tombé aussi bien que
l'empireche. Et les en fait on peut tout
à fait penser que la variole a diffusé
de manière
centripè centrifuge enfin fuge oui mais
par là enfin de l'intérieur vers
l'extérieur sur le plus loin mais
simplement on avait aucune notion de ce
qui se passait là où les les
conquistadors étaient pas présent aussi
parce qu'on dit toujours que la forêt
vierge amazonienne impénétrable il y
avait jamais personne. Là, les ce qu'on
apprend dans le bouquin et ce qu'on
apprenait par d'autres bouquins, c'est
grâce au Lidard, les techniques de car
vas-y. Alors, alors c'est vrai que si on
va un petit peu plus loin, on a
les on a les Espagnols qui sont au
niveau de l'Empire in casa, qui vont
vouloir chercher l'Eldorado. Moi, je me
souviens d'un film qui est ancien qui
s'appelle Agir ou la colère de Dieu où
c'est Koskinski qui qui joue le le rôle
enfin d'un conquistador qui va descendre
les rivières pour arriver jusqu'à
l'Amazonnie. Et là, il y a il y a plein
de villages en fait cette période là. Il
y a des villages, il y a des bourgs, il
y a il y a une vie importante et ensuite
quand on revient vers l'Amazonnie un ou
deux siècles après, on trouve plus
rien. Et euh ça, on sa on a fini par
remettre en cause les témoignages des
euh des Espagnols, par exemple qui ont
fait cette première descente de
l'Amazonnie en se disant bah ça va, ils
ont baratiné. Surtout que ils avaient un
peu laissé les copains derrière et
cetera. Donc c'est pour que ils aient
pas trop d'ennui mais en réalité très
récemment et c'est aussi ce qui permet
de de voir ces écatombes très récemment
s aperçu que la forêt amazonienne elle
était entropisée. Il y a l'homme avait
beaucoup joué. Alors effectivement avec
une sorte de radar qui s'appelle le
Lidar, on peut on peut voir qu'il y
avait des routes. On peut voir à travers
la canopée. On voit à travers la canopée
qu'il y avait des des routes, pas des
chemins, des routes, pas des sentiers.
Et euh on a pu on pu voir aussi que la
terre à certains endroits est une terre
qui est riche en petit fragment d'os, en
petit fragment de céramique et cetera.
Et donc euh comment ça s'appelle cette
terre là ? Terra Preta je crois c'est un
un nom comme ça. Oui. Très fertile issu
de beaucoup plus fertile parce que la la
forêt signateur de la forêt est très peu
fertile et qui montre que ça veut dire
que pendant des centaines d'années, elle
a été fertilisée fertilisée par les les
débris de de d'arête de poisson. les os
et tout ça. Ils ont fait du compostage
comme dans le 12e arrondissement de
Paris. C'est ça. C'est pas tout à fait
pareil. On faut pas mettre le poisson et
les et les os, je crois, dans le
compostage. Peut-être. Mais il faut
mettre le poisson pour faire partir le
maïs. Peut-être. Oui. Oui. Ça c'est
Alors bon, on sait pas d'où ça vient.
C'est en tout cas partout là c'est un
point un point d'un point de vue
méthodologique l'arrivée des des méthode
d'anthropologie a venu est venu
compléter le les les méthodes des
historiens et en particulier il y a eu
une période où on ne jurait que par les
recensements mais les recensements ils
ont eu lieu des fois 100 ans 200 ans
après l'arrivée des des premiers colons
et donc après les premières épidémies et
donc on sous-estimait les populations.
Maintenant, on pense que dans les
Amériques, il y avait autour de 50 60
millions de personnes. En 1650, il y a
plus que 6 millions de personnes. Et
c'est à ce point que certains travaux
comme il y avait moins de monde, les
forêts s'étaient réendues, en
particulier en Amérique du Nord, la
prairie avait diminué et comme il y
avait moins de monde, plus d'arbres, la
température de la le carbone a été
piégé, la température de la la planète a
un peu baissé. une partie de cette
baisse serait liée à cette cet
ensauvagement en quelque sorte des
Amériques lié elle-même aux écatombes.
Et si on veut continuer sur les
écatombes, bien le la meilleure
démonstration, elle m'a été donnée par
un anthropologue qui s'appelle
Christophe Sand qui est venu nous faire
une conférence à à Sorbonne université
et il avait fait un bouquin. Lui, il est
d'origine de Nouvelle-Calédonie et il a
enquêté sur 52 territoires différents en
Océanie et à chaque fois finalement il
retombe un peu sur les mêmes choses,
c'est-à-dire une diminution très
importante de l'ordre de 90 % de la
population, des fois
plus sans qu'il y ait vraiment eu de
guerre de conquête. Là, on a
complètement des choses euh différentes,
mais simplement des baleigners qui
s'arrêtent, des
explorateurs
Bouinville, Cou, Vancouver qui vont
comme ça explorer et à chaque fois quand
il passent finalement ils reviennent 10
ans ou 20 ans après ou même 2 ans après
et il s'est passé une épidémie, il s'est
passé et là on a une manière beaucoup
plus fiable de mesurer la population
parce que c'est les petites îles et
c'est plus facile pour les explorateurs
d'avoir une idée de la population
d'emblé. Quand on est face à un
continent, on en voit qu'une petite
partie. Quand on est sur une petite île,
on envoie une plus grande partie. Il y a
un biais cognitif et un biais un biais
culturel. C'est-à-dire on peut pas
imaginer nous, on se met dans la peau
d'un espagnol ou d'un portugais, on peut
pas imaginer qu'il y a une autre culture
que la nôtre qui a pu qui a pu résoudre
des problèmes de denification de
population.
parce queon est quand même les
meilleurs. On on a on a Dieu avec nous
et eux il faut les christianiser. Donc
pour ça c'est le récit le récit
effectivement le le récit national de
différents pays. Alors le plus
caractéristique c'est les États-Unis. On
va pouvoir démarrer sur le sur les
États-Unis. Dieu Dieu a a offert un
territoire. Alors, c'est pas la première
colonie. La première colonie américaine
qui se soit stabilisée, c'est Jamestone.
Là, c'est euh c'est pas Dieu, c'est la
c'est le business c'est le business du
tabac d'ailleurs qui qui s'est mis en
place. donc qui s'est mis euh en place à
Jamestone euh qui euh euh fait que en
fait chaque année depuis 1607 venait euh
à peu près euh euh enfin venait
peut-être 100 200 personnes, il en
mourait la moitié, ils en remettaient,
il en mourait la moitié, il en
remettait. C'était quand même un
carnage. Euh en gros, jusqu'en 1620, il
y a à peu près 5000 personnes qui sont
venues. Il en restait que 1200 en donc
et puis le dogme de l'époque, il y avait
pas une comète qui
passait évidemment que après il y a
plein plein d'explication 1618 avec les
Ind les Indiens du coin se on va repérer
la comète mais c'est plus dans
l'histoire du Mflower et donc le le M
Flower c'est 1620 ils vont à Plaimousse
ils viennent de Plaimous en Angleterre
ils vont à PL là qu' vont appeler
Et eux, ils arrivent sur une terre où
allez quasiment tout le monde est mort.
Il y avait déjà, on est en 1620, il y a
plein de bateaux qui passaient, il y
avait du commerce, il y avait des
échanges.
D'ailleurs, ils ont profité pour prendre
de temps en temps capturer quelques
indiens pour les ramener comme esclaves
et ils s'installent, ils sont enfin à ce
moment-là finalement au moment où les
pèlerins du MFower arrivent, c'est la
deuxième
colonie anglaise qui
s'installe et qui va rester, et bien
tout le monde est mort dans le coin.
le village et le la population, la tribu
indienne du coin est
morte. Il reste plus que quelques là où
il y en avait 10000 12000, il reste plus
qu'un millier de d'indiens et qui sont
en plus menacés par les copains enfin
les les tribus voisines qui se disent
tiens voilà peut-être un territoire à
récupérer. Donc ils vont faire alliance
en quelque sorte avec les pèlerins qui
savent rien faire. savent pas faire la
guerre, ils savent pas cultiver, ils
savent rien faire vraiment. Mais par
contre eux pour eux ils voient cette
terre, c'est Dieu qui leur a donné.
C'est une terre promise. C'est c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui euh qui les a
euh euh voilà, c'est un cadeau qui leur
est fait. Eux, ils se posent pas la
question. Les pauvres personnes, ils voi
alors l'épidémie a été terrible. On sait
pas trop la cause hein, mais l'épidémie
a été terrible. Donc, il y a des
cadavres partout. Euh non, on est c'est
pas forcément que ça pue. Ça fait des
années, enfin c'est passé un an ou deux,
mais enfin il y a des squelettes, il y a
il y a tout et ils sont sur cette terre
là et bah voilà, ça veut dire que c'est
leur terre. Et donc dans le dans le
récit, on va avoir des choses
importantes. Toujours dans le récit des
de des Amériques, je vous ai parlé de de
ces esclaves qui il y en a un qui
s'appelle Tiscantom ou Squanto et ben
justement il est de ce village là. il a
réussi à revenir. Il a été pris, il
s'est retrouvé esclave en Espagne, est
parti vers il a il s'est démerdé, est
parti vers l'Angleterre. de
l'Angleterre, il est revenu euh et euh
il est là et il parle anglais et donc il
va faire l'intermédiaire et il va
organiser et c'est comme ça que va y
avoir ce ce mythe de l'alliance entre
les Indiens du coin et les Américains
avec le Thanksgiving qui est vraiment le
don qui a été fait à ce moment-là pour
aider.
Oui, les dons des Indiens. Et puis
Jamestone, on a un autre myth, c'est
Pocaontas. Enfin, Poca, elle a existé.
Euh, elle est euh elle est effectivement
elle a épousé la fille d'un chef indien,
elle a épousé un le chef euh anglais
John Wolf ou un truc comme ça, enfin euh
qu'importe son nom. Euh et il euh elle
est partie en Angleterre d'ailleurs au
bout d'un certain temps. Elle est morte
assez vite là-bas parce que je pense
qu'elle a chopé les maladies du coin. On
elle s'appelait alors Rebecca et elle
elle est morte mais Pocaontas et tout
ça. Enfin vous le truc de Disney là
encore cette vision euh bah il faut la
il faut la confronter à la manière dont
ça se passait à Jamestone à ce moment-là
où c'était la cata quoi enfin vraiment.
Et d'ailleurs quand peu de temps après
les il y a à nouveau eu le des combats
avec les Indiens, ils ont fallilli tous
s'y passer et puis au même en même temps
avec tous ces Américains, tous ces
Anglais qui arrivaient, les épidémies
qui se plaçaient et cetera et petit à
petit ça a fait de la place et puis ça a
donné cette idée que les États-Unis,
enfin c'est pas encore les États-Unis,
l'Amérique est un endroit
où c'est pour les Anglais, c'est pour ou
les Européens, c'est pour les religieux
Et les sauvages et ben il y a qu'à les
chasser. Il y a qu'à les chasser. Il y a
qu'à les tuer. Et c'est comme ça que se
va se construire euh l'Amérique. Euh ils
ont utilisé quelques petites armes
bactériologiques de l'époque ou pas ?
Alors ça vient plus tard. Euh dans la
naissance des États-Unis, d'abord la
première chose pour les Anglais, c'était
de les Français dehors. Nousons
réussi. C'était assez facile parce que
la France c'est une un terrain enfin un
un pays plus européen,
plus de terroir et moins de navigateurs
que l'été l'Angleterre. Quand on vit en
Angleterre ou dans des coins comme ça,
on a envie de partir. Euh mais quand on
est quand on voit la bouffe, c'est ça ?
Quand on voit la bouffe, non, je sais
pas. Mais en tout cas euh il y a un vrai
problème et ils peuvent difficilement
s'en sortir s'il y a une augmentation de
population. La France avait du
territoire. Donc euh il y avait moins de
monde de l'autre côté côté alors en
France c'était au Canada. Et euh donc
euh les Anglais ont commencé par nous
dehors euh de du Canada et puis à
la guerre franco euh en des anglais
contre les les Français puis avec les
tribus indiennes d'un côté et de l'autre
mais beaucoup plus finalement
franco-indienne d'un côté et anglais de
l'autre. Et là, ils sont du côté de la
région des grands lacs. Les Anglais, ils
ont récupéré cette zone-là et euh ben il
remettent en cause le l'équilibre qu'il
y avait entre les trappeurs qui venaient
de France, qui voulaient plutôt faire du
commerce et récupérer des pots mais pas
pas s'installer, faire de l'agriculture
et là c'est les choses sont en train de
changer. Il y a un chef indien qui
s'appelle Pontiac qui va fédérer les
tribus du coin et comme la voiture P O N
T I A C Je pense que oui effectivement
euh et donc qui va faire la guerre au
aux anglais et la la situation est pas
toujours très facile et c'est là
qu'effectivement le général qui gouverne
les forces anglaises sur place on esté
en 1663 a une correspondance avec un
colonel qui est à auquel il conseille de
distribuer des couvertures avec de la
variole, ça a été fait mais c'est euh on
sait pas trop ce que ça a fait comme
conséquence. Donc j'avais raison.
Pontiac fait référence au chef indien.
Voilà. Donc ça s'appelle les guerres de
Pontiac.
Donc effectivement et donc c'est la
première alors il y a une première
tentative c'est pendant la peste en en
1346 à CAFA en Crimé. le siège de Caf,
les Mongols, les Tatars sont autour à
l'intérieur, c'est un comptoir génois et
ils ont la la peste. Et donc pour se
venger de ce coup du sort, ils balancent
avec des trébuchers et balancent leur
cadavre à l'intérieur de la ville pour
embaumer la ville en quelque sorte parce
qu'on pensait que c'était les miasmes et
donner la peste au aux génois. Alors,
probablement que ça a transmis la peste
localement. Après, c'est la plutôt la
reprise du commerce entre cette
partie-là finalement le il y a
l'Ukraine, il y a le blé et cetera,
enfin l'actuelle Ukraine et euh qui a
permis de au au blé et au rat et à leur
puce de rediffuser sur la Méditerranée
et de donner la peste noire très peu de
temps après. Mais c'est aussi un acte de
guerre comme ça avec finalement la
volonté de transmettre une maladie à
l'ennemi comme quoi euh ça existait. Et
ça aussi c'est un point important dans
le on peut pas partir du principe que on
ne sera jamais dans une situation où on
n'aura pas envie un jour quelqu'un
n'aura pas envie de filer une
épidémie à d'autres pour une raison x ou
y. Donc on garde ça un peu dans notre
tête pour savoir un peu comprendre ce
qui va se passer plus tard. Très
récemment, les Américains là, ils ont
pas chopé des Chinois avec euh un ergo
de sègle trafiqué pour faire des
recherches. Euh tu as pas suivi ça ? Il
y a plein de de choses
récentes. Les pires les pires choses qui
ont pu y avoir, c'est l'unité 731 en
pleine deuxème guerre mondiale. Les des
Japonais qui essayent de balancer la
peste par exemple par voie aéroporté sur
une province
chinoise. Euh des essais pour tester
toutes les saloperies sur les
prisonniers chinois. Donc là, il y a
vraiment quelque chose de terrible et on
voit que il y a c'est nos limites, c'est
comment on peut détruire avec des
microbes et puis euh quelques accidents
tout à fait douteux comme cet accident à
Nova Sibirs qui est euh
de euh charbon en fait c'est ils avaient
Oui, c'est l'entrax, c'est la même
chose. Le bassile du charbon euh qui le
charbon peut-être c'est on l'utilise
plus en médecine vétérinaire. Et puis en
dans l'histoire aussi, mais c'est
l'entraxe et euh un système d'aération
d'un laboratoire militaire qui est qui
était défaillant et tout d'un coup des
nuages de sport qui partent dans la
population et euh Elsine finira par le
reconnaître. Donc après la chute du mur
de Berlin, c'était bien des des un truc
militaire et cetera
et minimum une petite centaine de morts
mais probablement beaucoup plus. Donc on
voit bien quand même que euh on garde un
petit peu euh l'idée que euh utiliser
des microbes pour en faire la guerre et
pas un truc qui est complètement euh euh
exclu. Il y a des êtres humains qui
pensent à ça. Je j'ouvre une parenthèse
histoire de faire une petite pause
historique et après on reviendra dans
l'histoire et peut-être à l'Océanie et
surtout à l'Afrique et et après oui le
le l'antrax. Vous vous rappelez les les
anglais et puis certaines institutions
qui recevaient des petites enveloppes
avec de la farine dedans ? Alors oui,
mais avant d'être de la farine, il y a
eu des vraies enveloppes d'entrax. Oui,
ça c'était quelqu'un qui
travaillait à Fort des tri Maryland. Ah
bah mince alors. Et juste une question
pour qui était fâché la c'est juste
après les attentats de du 11 septembre.
Le l'entraxe en question avait été
fariné si je peux me
permettre des sports maisort en terme
nano, c'est-à-dire que c'était de
l'entraxe militarisée. On a reconnu que
c'était de l'entraxe militarisé. On a
reconnu sa provenance et celui qui a été
suspecté de l'avoir fait s'est suicidé.
Donc après, il y a pas eu de Comment il
s'appelait ? Je me souviens plus de son
nom mais il s'est suicidé. il a il a
jamais été jugé mais c'était peu après
le 11 septembre et il le motif c'était
que il l'avait mauvaise parce que
finalement on il pouvait plus continuer
à faire ce qu'il faisait. On reviendra
sur les labos, les entraxes et tous les
bassiles militarisés ou du moins les
recherches de gains de fonction. Mais il
y a pas besoin il y a pas besoin de truc
militarisé. Il faut se rappeler que le
dernier cas de Variol à Birmingham, je
crois pas que ce soit un labo militaire.
En tout cas, c'était une photographe qui
était même pas dans le labo mais qui
était à l'étage au-dessus et par l'air
et c'est la dernière personne à être
morte de la
vari, c'est
Bruce Irvin. Non, c'est ça. Oui, Bruce
Irvin qui était chercheur de du
laboratoire P4 militaire de Ford Dirique
au Marineland spécialisé dans les armes
biologiques. Et je vous conseille
d'ailleurs un très bon documentaire d'un
très bon ami qui s'appelle Bob Cohen qui
a écrit et qui a réalisé pour un
documentaire qui s'appelle Antrax War et
et la guerre de l'Antrax. Je vous le
conseille c'est pas un piquet ce sera
très volé donc reporteur de guerre
extraordinaire un mec extraordinaire.
une précision justement c'est
effectivement Hin euh mais je ne me
souviens plus je me souvenais plus
exactement quand je serai dans des
situations comme ça je diraiis je me
souviens plus du nom et puis comme ça et
vous vous chercherez euh en gros tout ce
que j'essaie de dire euh vous pouvez le
vérifier et c'est euh donc comme ça ça
veut dire que de temps en temps j'ai
l'air d'avoir des approximations. C'est
pas facile de se souvenir de tout. Ça
veut pas dire que j'ai pas cherché le
nom à un moment ou un autre, mais je
préfère pas balancer un nom comme ça
juste pour le truc. Et si une date, je
la connais pas ou si l'écriture de des
voitures Pontiaqu je la connais pas
exactement c'est quelque chose faire ça
va être une règle du jeu un peu dans ce
c'est ma manière de fonctionner ici on
est sur Syerview les sources doit être
carrées
cubiquangulé et de bonne qualité et moi
c'est encore pire je suis professeur à
l'université et je dis des choses qui
sont des fois gênantes si en plus je
disais des conneries ce serait être
complètement discrédité
revenons
à l'occéanie un petit peu. Alors,
j'aimerais quand
même est-ce qu'on passe tout de suite à
l'Océanie ou est-ce qu'on on se pose la
question de si en fin de compte
l'Afrique avait commencé sa colonisation
de l'Europe avant les
Européens, sans les techniques de soins
européennes, est-ce que l'Afrique aurait
pris le pas ? Alors et je vais venir
peut-être parce que il y a une étape
fondamentale dans le dans le
raisonnement. C'est c'est une
démonstration que j'essaie de faire
aussi sur le rôle des écatombes dans le
fait que euh quand on prend les
Amériques, l'Océanie, on parle soit
anglais, soit espagnol, soit portugais,
un petit peu français. Et cette
démonstration, elle passe aussi par la
guerre d'indépendance des États-Unis. Et
puis ce qui se passe un peu, on a parlé
de la guerre de Pontiac, très vite, on
arrive à la guerre d'indépendance.
Pourquoi le Canada est resté euh sous la
euh sous la fule des anglais ? Pourquoi
les États-Unis ont une indépendance ?
Pourquoi ensuite la France qui a
récupéré la Louisiane l'a perdu aussitôt
et pourquoi c'est finalement la
puissance américaine s'est constituée ?
Et là, on va encore comprendre tel le
poids des microbes et l'intelligence
aussi de certaines personnes quand même.
Et je veux rendre hommage à George
Washington pour son intelligence
microbiologique sans connaître les
microbes. Euh donc guerre
d'indépendance et là on a on commence à
avoir on est autour de
1775 76. les euh euh les Américains en
ont marre de payer enfin les les anglais
américains on ont marre de payer les
impôts et de pas être représentés et euh
ils commencent à se rebeller et euh ils
vont essayer assez rapidement
d'embarquer le Canada avec eux. Alors,
le Canada, il est plutôt
francophone. Il y a des anglais qui
dirigent, mais ils se disent "Les
Français peut-être, les francophones
vont peut-être nous aider à les
Anglais dehors et cetera." et ils
partent pour prendre Québec et là ils
échouent sur le l'attaque de Québec
parce que ils essayent pendant une
tempête de neige et ils font le siège et
pendant le siège ils sont bloqués par la
variole et ils perdent énormément de
monde et finalement ils sont absolument
incapables de reprendre la guerre après
et ils arrêtent là.
Et à ce moment-là, l'occasion est
perdue. Les anglais tiennent Québec,
tiennent Montréal, tiennent le Canada et
c'est terminé. Il y aura plus l'occasion
pour les Américains de reprendre, sauf
peut-être dans quelques années quand
Trump aura repris le Canada, on sait
jamais. Mais pour l'instant, c'est pas
le cas. Et euh on a à ce moment-là le
siège de Boston. Ils veulent pas avoir
la même histoire. Rappelez-vous les
Anglais, enfin les Européens, la variole
c'est quelque chose qui c'est une
maladie infantil. Les soldats qui
viennent d'Europe sont immunisés
naturellement. Les Américains eux la le
la concentration de population est moins
importante. Donc ça donne des épidémies
mais ça s'installe pas définitivement.
Et donc la grande peur de Washington,
c'est d'avoir une épidémie variole dans
ses troupes. Donc il fait le siège de
Boston, il arrive à faire partir les
Anglais. Même pour rentrer dans Boston,
il va regarder dans ses troupes les gens
qui ont des cicatrices de varies pour y
aller et il va même faire la variation.
le vaccin n'est pas encore inventé, mais
en utilisant des euh de le virus de la
variole lui-même, par contact, par Oui.
par grattage, il va varioliser ses
troupes, euh leur donner la variole
volontairement mais dans des conditions
où transmission par la par la peau qui
est un petit peu moins grave. Euh
évidemment, de manière la plus discrète
possible pour que les anglais ne s'en
aperçoivent pas. Il y avait des
courriers de Washington et il arrive
comme ça à varier ses troupes. Donc
c'est et là où l'assymétrie jouer contre
lui, les anglais avaient les virus de
leur côté, il les avait le le virus de
la variole était un danger pour les
Américains. Il a réussi à compenser ça
et donc ça lui a permis de gagner à la
fin. Première guerre bactériologique
avec traitement. Voilà, c'est le
traitement a cassé une asymétrie. Sinon,
il y avait une
asymétrie. Très peu de temps après, il y
a la révolution française. La révolution
française avec les grands principes et
contre
l'esclavage. Et la principale colonie
française, c'était Saint-Domingue, la
perle des Antilles. 500000 esclaves
tenus par quelques dizaines de milliers
de de blancs et de mulatâtres qui
étaient un peu entre les deux. Donc une
très grande majorité d'esclaves qui
finalement
bah apprennent qu'ils sont affranchis et
ensuite ça pose problème d'un point de
vue économique. Napoléon prend le
pouvoir et dit ça va ces conneries on
arrête maintenant revient esclavage et
tout ça ça plaît pas. Qu'importe, il
envoie son beau-frère, sa sœur Pauline
Bonaparte, son beau-frère s'appelle
Lecler et il y va avec non pas quelques
centaines de conquistador mais avec des
dizaines de milliers de soldats,
peut-être 20 et quelques millen en
arrivera d'autres. Ils arrivent, c'est
le mois de février. Haïti, je connais
bien, février, il pleut pas énormément.
Ce qu'on appelle la saison sèche, pas
totalement mais la saison sèche, les
maladies se transmettent pas trop, mais
arrive la saison des pluies. Donc là,
ils prennent le contrôle des plaines,
des villes ou de ce qu'il en reste parce
qu'elles ont été brûlées. Les esclaves,
les neiges marrons les vont se mettre
dans les membres, dans les montagnes. Il
prend il prend le pouvoir,
il les même tout seul l'ouverture, le
chef des esclaves et même euh se
rend peu de temps après, il a arrêté, il
a envoyé à la celle le joue.
généraux aussi sont avec les lecler et
ça a l'air de de se passer très bien. Et
à ce
moment-là, il arrive que des moustiques
qui étaient qui avaient été amenés
depuis l'Afrique par l'esclavage àedes
Égypti moustique qui transmet la fièvre
jaune donc la fièvre jaune qui était
arrivée pareil et le paludisme qui était
arrivé pareil en fait ils étaient plus
ou moins en terre africaine avec une
population
africaine. la terre africaine en terme
de de type de paysage et de type de
maladie. Le palud, sa fièvre jaune,
fièvre jaune, c'est des maladies qui
venaient d'Afrique. Les esclaves
venaient d'Afrique, étaient nés en
Afrique et avait une certaine immunité,
une certaine résistance à ces maladies.
Les soldats européens eux et ben ils
jouaient avec les maladies contre eux.
Et nos dizaines de milliers de soldats
napoléoniens, il en est rien resté. Il
en est resté peut-être 2000 à la fin à
la bataille de vertière. Ils sont
partis, les Anglais les attendaient au
large pour les faire prisonnier.
Terminé. L'expédition des dizaines de
milliers de soldats, les troupes
napoléoniennes, c'est pas n'importe
quoi, contre des milliers d'esclaves
mais mal armés, mal organisés. C'est les
esclaves qui ont gagné parce que les les
microbes étaient avec eux. Donc on voit
vraiment le poids des microbes avec
cette histoire de l'Océanie, cette
histoire de euh de le de l'Amérique, euh
les destructions de population, les
écatombes, on voit vraiment que le poids
des microbes, c'est pas simplement une
impression. Tous les éléments sont là
concordants pour montrer que c'est eux
qui ont fait la loi à ce moment-là.
Microbe ou parasite ? Euh le plasmonium,
l'agent du paludisme est un parasite
mais il est microscopique. Moi, je
l'inclus dans les
microbes. Dernière chose, Napoléon
venait de récupérer la Louisiane. La
Louisiane, c'est-à-dire tout ce qui
bordait le Mississippi depuis euh les
grands lacs jusque jusqu'à la côte du
Golfe du Mexique. Et là, dégoûté et sans
avoir plus sa base arrière, il s'est dit
"Vaut mieux vendre." et il a vendu la
Louisiane aux Américains et donc ça a
permis aux Américains de ne plus avoir
de frontières à l'ouest. Il restait plus
que les plaines et ils sont allés les
plaines, les rocheuses et cetera et ils
sont allés jusqu'à jusqu'au Pacifique.
Ils ont repris des territoires aux
Espagnols et c'est créé le la grande
puissance qui est États-Unis mais aussi
le mythe de la conquête de l'Ouest, les
Américains de cette terre bénie de Dieu
et cetera. Tout ça est lié finalement
avec ce contexte. Personne où il y a eu
presque personne selon eux. Ah ben de
moins en moins grâce à eux.
Il faut pas rigoler avec ça. Revenons,
revenons avec C'est évidemment grâce à
eux est entre entre guillemets. Ouais.
Les les Indiens s'en souviennent. Oui.
Et euh juste une parenthèse avant,
j'aimerais qu'on reparte un petit peu en
Océanie un peu après, puis qu' ensuite
qu'on réactualise pour 2025. L'Afrique,
on on se met dans le cas suivant.
Imaginez-vous que les africains décident
de conquérir
l'Europe en 1300 ou en 1400.
amenant leur miasme en Europe, ça aurait
fait quoi ? Ça marche pas. Pourquoi ça
marche pas ? Ils avaient pas la
technologie. Non non. Alors déjà, ils
avaient un certain nombre de maladies.
Il y a pas de cavalerie africaine. Les
chevaux ont un mal fou à survivre euh au
cœur de l'Afrique à cause d'une maladie
qui est la maladie du sommeil, la
tripanosomiase, la CC, la mousse CC. Et
alors ? Euh, on va dire bah ouais mais
il y a enfin il y a les
zèbres. Les zèbres c'est difficile de
dominer. Oui. Non mais non, c'est c'est
un truc en parasitologie à cause des
rayures noir et blanc, les mouches ont
du mal à atterrir. C'est une des raisons
et c'est en tout cas sérieusement
envisagé par les parasitologues et les
zèbres qui ont le cuir pas trop pas trop
épais parce que après il y a les buffles
et tout ça enfin il y a il y a plein
d'autres animaux et finalement les
chevaux sont beaucoup plus vulnérables
que les zèbres à la maladie du sommeil.
Donc pas de
cavalerie, pas de char et cetera. Donc
déjà pour venir attaquer l'Europe, c'est
pas c'est pas top. Et en plus leurs
maladies, elles sont pas alors elles
sont
exportables dans un du côté de de zones
de voilà de zones tropicales à zone
tropicale.
Mais pas en nord- sud. Et ça a toujours
été ça d'ailleurs leurasie.
C'est pourquoi les Européens ont tant de
maladies ? Parce que en fait toutes les
maladies qui ont émergé depuis le le
l'extrémité de l'Europe, extrémité
occidentale jusqu'à la Chine finalement
pouvait circuler assez facilement. Donc
il y a il y a une certaine logique et
aller du nord au sud les maladies ont
plus de mal. Première chose, donc
finalement, ils auraient pas amené alors
le paludisme a existé hein quand même en
Europe, mais n'avait pas la même ne
faisait pas la même pression, sauf
peut-être en Italie à Rome, c'était
terrible. Rome lors de l'Empire romain
ou Rome après à la Renaissance, il y a
le paludisme c'était une calamité mais
après c'était plutôt des territoire un
peu un peu spécifique. Donc il aurait
pas eu le même impact que la variole a
eu. Par exemple la variole, la rouge la
tuberculose et cetera et cetera ont eu
dans les Amériques. Les vecteurs de
propagation de la tuberculose euh c'est
la vraiment le la respiration euh c'est
la tou euh le bassile le bassile réside
dans la terre dans Ouais. Non, il est
dans les poumons. Alors là, c'est c'est
un bassile qui est complètement inféodé
à l'homme. Tellement il est inféodé à
l'homme qui nous sert un peu de greffier
pour euh en s'en sert pour voir un peu
quels ont été les mouvements de
population. au moment des émergences de
différents lignages de la tuberculose,
on va pouvoir mettre en évidence les
grands mouvements historiques. Par
exemple, puisqu'on en a beaucoup parlé,
il y a un lignage qui s'appelle le
lignage SL4 qui est en Europe
probablement depuis l'antiquité qui est
donc là à la fin du Moyen-Âge, au début
de la Renaissance. Et ce lignage L4, on
va le trouver euh dominant maintenant
dans les Amériques, dans les Caraïbes
évidemment, Amérique du Nord, Amérique
du Sud en Océanie. Marqueur temporel,
marqueur d'une époque où les microbes
européens ont colonisé le monde. Quand
je vous entends, qui dit microbe, qui
dit euh business, qui dit guerre ? Oui.
Est-ce que on on fait l'Océanie
maintenant ou on se fait le Ah benah
l'Océanie, l'Océanie, on on en a déjà
parlé finalement. On peut on peut dire
que c'est la même chose en Australie,
sauf que l'Australie, ça d'abord été
alors c'est très à la mode, une colonie
pénitentiaire euh pour les Anglais. Donc
euh là, bon, au moins, ils voyaient les
choses en grand quand même. Ils ont pris
un continent parce que Saint-Pierre et
Miclon ou le Bagne en Guyane, c'est
quand même un peu petit. Mais là,
c'était c'était la même chose. C'était
ça a servi à mettre les bagnards et les
forces et ils ont amené évidemment
pareil la la tuberculose, la variole et
toutes ces maladies et les aborigènes
sont morts en très grande quantité. Là
encore, on est autour de 90 % dans les
estimations avant avant de parler des et
la syphilis si la syphilis ma préf est
une est quelque chose qui a qui a fait
énormément de dégâts en
Océanie parce que euh ça venait en fait
en fait faire une synergie avec la
grippe, la tuberculose, des maladies qui
agissaient relativement vite,
tuberculose un peu intermédiaire et la
syphilis ben elle jouait sur le
renouvellement des générations avec la
stérilité. Et la syphilis, c'est les
marins qui l'amené évidemment. Donc donc
en gros, la syphilis ça a stérilisé les
locaux. On peut tuer les gens leur
faisant l'amour.
Enfin faut imaginer les marins. Il est
très fort quoi. C'est ça. Faut faut
aimer ça hein quand même. Il devait
puer. Enfin c'est la pistilence. Oui.
Ils avaient le score but. C'était pas
top hein quand même. Mais euh motivé je
pas je sais pas. Vous avz peut-être pas
le choix. Oui oui c'est compliqué. Il y
a certaines sociétés qui étaient
permissives et qui offraient les les
femmes qui offraient leurs femmes comme
ça pour avoir la paix et pour avoir des
clous des clous du
fer. Il y a ça a posé des problèmes à
certaines escales parce que les
capitaines disaient "Mais arrêtez
d'enlever les clous du bateau, on en a
besoin quand même sinon." Et donc ça ça
a été vraiment mais il y avait pas de
fer en Océanie et c'était une monnaie
d'échange les femmes contre le fer. Ça
vaut pas un clou ? Ouais, ben ça valait
quelque chose avec le faire. Ça vaut
quelque chose. Euh avant qu'on passe sur
les biaillets cognitifs, les conflits
d'intérêt et la parole
scientifique, réchauffement climatique,
ça va faire bouger quelques petits
miasmes d'Afrique vers le Nord. Bah
déjà, moi les miasmes, j'y crois pas
bien. Donc je préfère de Je suis
complètement acquis à la théorie des
microbes. La théorie miasmatique était
là jusqu'au 19e siècle. exprès hein. Oui
oui, j'imagine mais j'en profite. Elle a
tenu quand même 23 siècles entre
Hippocrate et le 19e siècle. Euh les
miasme par exemple qui expliquait le
choléra. On parle pas des dogmes et
ainsi de suite. Oui oui mais pendant
justement on peut en parler là ça
réchauffement climatique he parce que
j'ai rien à
dire si le réchauffement climatique il
fait changer les zones de nos microbes
préférés africains comme la fièvre
ébola, le moustique tigre. Non mais même
le si on prend évidemment on a quelques
risques de il y a le moustique tigre
effectivement qui s'installe en région
parisienne. Il y a beaucoup de plus de
cas importés de donc beaucoup la
mondialisation parce que c'est les cas
importés de la Réunion, des Antilles, le
nombre de Pakistan ou éventuellement
mais enfin pour la France c'est quand
même la Réunion les Antilles qui sont
les les endroits où il y a le plus de
voyageurs entre la France et et un
territoire enfin la France
métropolitaine et un territoire où il y
a de la transmission du Chikogunia par
exemple ou de la dingue. Mais donc il va
y avoir effectivement des problèmes. Il
va y avoir des épidémies mais d'une
certaine dimension, pas de pas pas des
grandes catastrophes, y compris en
France métropolitaine de maladies comme
la dingue ou le
chikongunia, mais ça va pas bouleverser
complètement le le monde. il y a bien
d'autres choses qui vont bouleverser le
monde et même en terme d'épidémie
pour pas trop se focaliser sur le
déplacement qui est d'ailleurs à la fois
le l'chauffement climatique mais aussi
le commerce le commerce des pneus le
commerce des containers le commerce des
plantes pour le virus shikongunia
transmis par Aedes Albopicus le
moustique tigre c'est d'abord le
commerce et c'est vraiment une
mondialisation
d'Aedes Albopictus qui a permis de
d'avoir du shingunia en plein endroit.
Il supporte relativement bien le froid.
Il est en train de s'installer au nord
des Alpes. Son copain, son cousin Laedes
Égypti, c'est lui qui a on en a parlé à
cause de la fièvre jaune. Lui, il reste
en zone tropicale. L'autre nom de la
fièvre jaune, c'est le virus, c'est
Amaril. Sinon, c'est la fièvre
jaune. Il y a pas On parle des dogmes.
Je parlais je tendais la perche avec les
miasmes. Je tendais la perche avec
j'aurais pu tendre la perche avec les
signiers et les humeurs. Hm, c'est
extraordinaire de penser que pendant 23
siècles, on va de - 400 et quelques du
temps
d'Hippocrate jusqu'à euh 2e partie du
19e siècle, on est on a un dogme. Les
maladies, c'est ce sont des troubles des
humeurs. Il y a quatre humeurs. La bile
jaune, la bile noire. On sait pas trop
ce que c'est que la bile noire, la
trabile, mais le sang, la lymphe. Et si
on est malade, ben c'est qu'il y a un
déséquilibre des humeurs. Souvent une
humeur en excès. Et si le la maladie se
traduit par exemple par des vomissements
de la diarrée, c'est une quelque chose
qui est chaud et humide en excès, ben il
y a trop de sang, on va saigner. Et donc
si on a le choléra et ben en tant
qu'affaire, pourquoi pas saigner les
gens ? Et on peut aussi alors il y avait
quand même des gens qui innovaient.
François Brousset euh j'ai récupéré un
cours de François Brousset. Il explique
en gros toutes les manières de tuer les
gens avec les traitements, avec les
saigners, les les purgatifs et cetera.
Des gens qui qu'on devait réhydrater et
qui au lieu de faire de d'avoir une
réhydratation, on les purgeait, on les
saignait. C'est pas bon pour la santé.
Ils étaient déjà en choc euh
hypovolémique, en perte de volume avec
la saignée, avec la les purgatifs, ça
les achevé. C'est très dommage ces ces
trucs-là parce que il y a quand même
quelqu'un qui avait pensé à donner de
l'eau salée. Il s'est dit mais ils
perdent de l'eau salée. On leur donne de
l'eau salée en particulier en
intrarectal. C'est un bon endroit pour
le pour le faire passer. Et il avait
expérimenté ça dans des
prisons en Angleterre. encore les
prisons. Oui. Oui. Alors les prisons en
tant qu'affaire euh jusque dans les
années 70 dans le Maryland et sur le
choléras. Donc c'est le choléas, ils ont
bien aimé et testé ça dans les dans les
prisons. Et là ils ont fait ça. Il y a
sur les militaires aussi ils aiment
bien. Peut-être. Alors on continue là.
Il il fait ça. Il dit ben voilà, il a
très peu de morts et là on va avoir un
magnifique raisonnement circulaire.
C'est les experts viennent et disent ben
non, il y a pas eu beaucoup de morts
donc c'est pas le
choléra. Donc il puisque le choléra, il
faut que les gens meurent. Il trouvent
un traitement, les gens meurent plus.
Alors c'était pas le choléra, son
traitement ne vaut rien.
1830 ou 31
32 la réhydratation dans le choléra et
dans les maladies d'éraïques. 1964.
Il s'est passé 132 ans avant qu'on
rectifie cette petite
erreur. Donc les dogmes sont solides. Et
quand pareil dans le genre toujours sur
le choléra John Snow épidémiologiste
capignon sur rue en Angleterre, il a
anesthésié la reine Victoria pour ses
accouchements. quand même, c'est pas
n'importe quel médecin euh à qui on
confie de mettre voilà de d'assommer la
la reine quoi avec de du chloroforme,
mais euh et bien il fait des super
enquêtes de terrain sur le sur le
choléra et il montre que c'est lié à
l'eau dans la ville de Londres,
l'approvisionnement en eau de
différentes manières, il le montre et
vraiment des études top.
il finit par dire ben c'est l'eau et
c'est probablement de l'eau souillée par
les les égouts. Il doit y avoir des
animal cul des petites des petits
animaux qui transmettent ça. Bah les
microbes quoi. Bon bien sûr il se fait
traiter de tous les noms par la revue le
Lancette laquelle avait déjà traité de
tous les noms notre celui qui avait fait
les le la réhydratation du choléra.
C'était eux encore. C'était eux encore.
Et alors le lancette a fini. Alors en
1858 John Snow, il a euh voilà une
petite
nécrologie dans dans le Land 7 où bon il
reconnaissent qu'il a servi pour le été
euh quelqu'un pour ce qui est de
l'anesthésie mais rien pas un mot et
quelque chose de de vraiment très sec
quand même sur cette histoire. Le lanet
a publié un
rectificatif en 2013. Ah, pas mal. Pas
donc euh la conduite introspective, les
dogmes, les euh la l'inertie de la de la
médecine quand même quelque chose
d'assez extraordinaire. Bon, moi j'en ai
euh j'en ai vu un peu des résultats sur
le choléra en Haïti avec des dogmes sur
le choléra environnemental qui sont
contredits par les études récentes et
qui continuent à nous être opposés. On
continue à me raconter qu'il y a du
choléra en Afrique de l'Ouest, à l'ouest
de euh dans par exemple au Sénégal. Ça
fait des années et des années qu'il y a
plus de choléra, mais n'empêche que il y
a des des études avec des modélisations
qui disent qu'il y a du choléra. Non, il
y a pas d'argent à gagner dans cette
histoire-là si ce n'est si ce n'est
quand même si si ce n'est dire il y a du
choléra un peu partout et il y a qu'une
solution, faut vacciner et le vaccin est
mauvais. Je vraiment je suis pour les
vaccins quand ils sont bons, beaucoup
moins quand ils sont pas bons, quand ils
sont pas efficaces. On parlera alors du
vaccin Covid, c'est plus
compliqué. On s'est fait un peu avoir.
Ah bon ? Ah oui, faut le reconnaître.
Alors, c'est pas 95 % de taux
d'immunité. C'était un peu surjoué. Ah
ouais, mais euh 70 bah ça a changé en
fait. Le virus changé. Ah, il mutait. Ça
c'est vrai. Ah ouais. Ouais. que euh
très clairement euh moi je pense qu'il a
quand même servi à ce au moment de euh
où on était en couvre-feu depuis des
mois et des mois couvrefeu avec un truc
aéroporté
confinement non c'est c'est pas top la
manière dont les choses ont été fait
prendre le café assis quand même un
petit café assis c'est mieux qu'un café
debout ou on reparlera de ça en fin
d'émission ça franchement c'est plus de
la médecine ça Ah bon
café
debout café café assis et les trucs
est-ce que ça fait repousser les cheveux
ça il faudra demander à Jean qui a ce
texte
j'ai pas de non une petite friction au
papier journal des fois ça sert à ça le
papier journal à se frictionner mais pas
c'est pas les cheveux normalement de
quoi ah si je te raconterai la blague.
Bon revenons au dog en dogme en
médecine. Il y en a d'autres des dogmes
? Ben, il y en avait bon ce dogme euh
enfin cette ignorance des microbes, elle
a duré longtemps alors qu'on les voyait
au
microscope. Et euh l'année de création
du microscope, c'est alors c'est euh
Anthony Van Lev qui en 1600 et des
poussières, c'est un drapier qui va
faire quelque chose qui permet de voir
des microbes. Donc il va les dessiner,
personne ne le croit vraiment. il veut
pas dire comment il fait ses lentilles.
Il est très bon pour faire les lentilles
et euh donc finalement on on laisse un
peu de côté mais au fur et à mesure
tiens sur le choléra euh Philippo Patini
au même moment où John Snow explique la
transmission par l'eau, il voit les les
les bassil en forme de virgule, il le
voit sur des nécropsies, sur des tissus
intestinaux de personnes mortes de
choléra. Personne ne le croit. Donc les
microbes ça existe pas ou ça en tout cas
ça a pas de lien avec les maladies
infectieuses et ça ne va arriver que
grâce à à Pasteur et sa manière
extrêmement spectaculaire. Non, non,
non, pas du tout. Euh très intuitif euh
pas du tout, il faisait comme ça, je
montre, pas du tout euh rigoureux. C'est
c'est pas ça là, c'est
l'intuition à une certaine un certain
instinct, une des intuitions qui étaient
bonnes, il pouvait l'aurait pu se
planter aussi, mais dans l'ensemble,
c'était des bonnes intuitions et l'art
l'art de la démonstration, l'art de la
de publiciser son travail. Euh par
exemple le premier truc où vraiment il
se fait remarquer, c'est dans une
controverse sur le la génération
spontanée. Quand on laissait un un
milieu euh euh qu'on avait stérilisé euh
à l'air, euh au bout de quelques temps,
il était plein de microbes. Donc les
microbes deaient se faire spontanément.
il a pris un un système avec des flacons
en colle de signe et là l'air ne pouvait
l'air pouvait rentrer mais les poussière
pouvait pas rentrer et à ce moment-là il
y avait plus de microbe. Quand il monte
en montagne, il y a beaucoup moins de
microbes, beaucoup moins de pollution
aussi. Et ça et dans ces cas-là, il il a
montré ça. Donc ça ça a été très euh
très marquant parce que la presse en a
beaucoup parlé. Et puis le peut-être le
truc le plus marquant, c'est la première
expérience de vaccination. Imaginons
qu'il ait un essai clinique à
faire. C'est contre le charbon, contre
l'entraxe. Euh, il le fait sur un
troupeau de de brebis. Il a euh il va
convoquer la presse. Il va injecter le
vaccin à la moitié d'un troupeau et pas
à l'autre moitié. Tout le monde va
pouvoir le voir. La presse, les
personnalités, tout ça, c'est pas très
loin de Paris en
cinéma. Et puis 3 semaines après, il
revient et là, il va leur filer le
charbon. Euh donc les leur injecter le
bassile du charbon, l'entraxe et là les
gens vont pouvoir voir les moutons
mourir dans les de tr jours. Il commence
à tomber malade et ils meurent et ceux
qui sont vaccinés ne meurent pas.
Ça quand même
démonstration comme spectaculaire de la
recherche même Didier Raout n'a pas
réussi à faire
plus sur la science la médecine et la
religion les dogmes. On reparlera des
dogmes en médecine et la longévité des
dogmes en médecine un peu plus ou pas du
tout ?
Est-ce que les religieux ont mis des
bâtons dans les roudes auprès des
médecins ? Non, ils ont raconté leurs
histoires. Euh, si on prend la la peste
de
Marseille, en fait, c'est là, ça permet
d'aborder la la question des récits. On
va le retrouver à chaque fois et on le
retrouve encore
aujourd'hui. Euh, on va le trouver sur
la syphilis. Prenons la peste de
Marseille. La vraie histoire, elle est
toute simple. Il y avait de la peste du
côté de la Syrie du Liban. On appelle ça
levant à l'époque. Un bateau qui était
parti de Marseille va ramener une
cargaision de de coton et surtout de
tissu précieux. Attends mais tout bien
un passage. Ils ont grugé la douane. Non
mais attends pardon. Donc ils sont ils
reviennent et pendant le le retour, ils
ont pris quelques passagers et là il y a
quand même en tout neuf morts euh le
temps qu'ils arrivent au large de
Marseille. problème, c'est que la
cargaison, elle appartient en grande
partie au premier échevin de la ville de
Marseille, premier magistrat.
Bon, quand même, on va pas la il faut la
mettre dans un îlo qui s'appelle l'île
de la jare. Il y a les les oiseaux de
mer et tout ça. Enfin, étendre le les
soirées, des tissus précieux dans un
endroit comme ça. Les embruns, ça abîme
la
marchandise. Donc, ils sont autorisés
exceptionnellement à mettre ça dans les
hangars au nord de Marseille dans un
crois qu'on appelle les infirmeries. Et
puis ben euh il commence à le la
personne qui s'occupe de de surveiller
le bateau meurt bizarrement. On dit
qu'il meurt de vieillesse et et comme ça
la peste évidemment avec les tissus
rentre dans Marseille, les tailleurs
commencent à être malade et mourir de la
peste et la peste se déclenche. Premier
récit, c'est celui que j'ai fait, c'est
récit par exemple de de médecins qui
travaillent à Marseille et qui disent
"C'est la
peste." Deuxème récit, euh quand même,
c'est un peu embêtant la peste. On va
faire venir C'est embêtant pour le
business. C'est embêtant pour le
business évidemment pour la réputation
de Marseille. On va faire venir alors il
y a pas l'OMS mais il y a l'Université
de Montpellier. Les sachants, les
sachants, ils arrivent, ils font leur
leur
enquête, il voit bien que c'est la peste
mais quand même ils négocient avec les
autorités locales et finalement ils vont
pas dire que c'est la peste mais une
fièvre contagieuse, dangereuse machin.
Mais ils disent pas que c'est la peste.
Grippe ou c'est pas une grippe ? Non
mais mais il négocie, c'est ça le point
important. Il négocie un peu comme
pendant le Covid quand les gens de l'OMS
ont négocié avec les autorités chinoises
les termes du rapport. Un peu comme lors
de l'épidémie d'Haïti, les le panel
indépendant a négocié avec l'ONU les
termes du rapport. Ça se négocie. Il
faut pas croire que on met n'importe
quoi et c'est très teinté de politique.
Donc là à Marseille il négocie et il
parle pas de de peste. Et bon à ce
moment-là, il y a 300 morts par jour. 15
jours plus tard, il y aura 1000 morts
par jour sur une ville de 80000
habitants dont 10000 sont partis. Ça
commence à faire beaucoup, hein. Ça va
pas durer longtemps cette histoire-là.
De c'est donc un deuxè récit. Et puis il
y a le 3e et 2e récit qui a marché d'une
certaine manière. Le capitaine capitaine
Château du du grand Saint-Antoine du
bateau a été en prison pendant 3 ans
puis après il a été libéré. Mais le
premier échevin, lui, il a été
décoré pour attitude euh attitude
héroïque pendant la pendant la peste. Et
puis la troisème la troisème histoire
évidemment c'est Monseigneur Belsin qui
dit que c'est parce que il y a des une
église réformée, il y a des gens séniste
à Marseille et que une mauvaise croyance
et le résultat fait que ben il y a la
pêche. Et donc il va faire une
procession, ça va mettre toutes les
autorités du coin une procession. La
paix c'est pas complètement finie mais
al il fait bien les choses et tout et
donc ces récits divergents plus les
histoires de comètes ou de choses comme
ça dans d'autres cas euh sont la monnaie
monnaie courante dans le dans l'histoire
des épidémies. Très vite on verra aussi
le récit de Fort des Trig dans le
Maryland laboratoire militaire. On a ça
en particulier dans le début de
l'épidémie de
sida. C'est exactement euh alors le
début de l'épidémie de sida euh c'est
une répétition générale de ce qu'on a eu
sur le Covid.
C'est un pangolin. Non, c'est pas le
pangolin. Mais par contre, c'est
l'histoire de d'un virus fait en
laboratoire fabriqué avec des bouts de
virus différents. un virus s'appelle
Visna et un autre HTLV et euh qui aurait
été donc euh fait à à fort des tri
essayé sur des prisonniers et euh
finalement euh ce serait parti dans les
villes américaines, New York et puis les
les grandes villes puis seraient partis
ailleurs. Et ça venait contrer le récit
d'une cause
naturelle en Afrique, celui que j'ai
fait déjà de des chimpanzés et cetera,
mais qui ne plaisait pas.
Mais je dis qu'il y a différents récits.
C'est pas l'histoire du chimpanzé, le
mec qui fait un câlin au chimpanzé.
C'est bien l'histoire du chimpanzé, mais
euh on va trouver un rapport euh qui est
écrit par des savants est allemands, les
épouses Segal, Jacob et Lili Segal, qui
vont écrire un rapport. Ce rapport, il a
tout l'air d'un rapport scientifique. Il
est complètement euh imbitable, enfin
mais on peut on peut le lire
effectivement et justement ça lui donne
une authenticité. Je crois même que les
auteurs y croyaient. Bah déjà Est
allemand on pose la question, c'est ça ?
Alors oui, c'est on est en Allemagne de
l'Est. Ils ont ils ont séjourné en
France, ils ont été résistants pendant
la guerre et puis ils sont ils étaient
communistes et ils se sont installés en
Allemagne de l'Est et là ils ont été
plus ou moins manipulés en tout cas par
la Stasie et on sait ça et par le KGB,
on sait ça parce que à la à la chute du
mur de Berlin un certain nombre
d'archives. Les Allemands ont bien ont
bien travaillé, ils ont tout détruit
mais les Bulgares ont gardé quelques
archives et finalement donc on connaît
cette opération et elle servait en fait
elle avait servi à déstabiliser la
politique américaine en Afrique au
moment de la conférence d'ar d'Araré. Et
donc euh on peut avoir ces discours-là
dans le cas de la peste de Marseille. Et
ben la la thèse euh on va dire
officielle euh finalement est fausse et
c'est vraiment la thèse, c'est la faute
au à la cargaison et cetera.
une faute de il y a voilà il y a des
choses qui sont absolument pas
excusables. Euh dans le cas du sida et
bien c'est la la vraie raison est
naturelle. Donc on c'est pas parce qu'il
va y avoir un récit d'une cause
naturelle versus une cause, on va dire
conspirationniste euh en tout cas euh
qui implique une responsabilité que
l'une ou l'autre sont exactes. Et si on
parle d'Haïti puisque j'ai fait
l'investigation, j'ai porté une cause
conspirationniste puisque j'ai expliqué
que c'est lié à la l'arrivée d'un
contingent de non de Népalé, de soldat
Népalé. Et
finalement euh ça a été démontré par
différentes études scientifiques et
finalement Ban Kimoun secrétaire général
de l'ONU a fini par demander pardon mais
sans vraiment y croire demander pardon
au peuple haïtien pour le comportement
de l'ONU au début de l'épidémie. Donc si
je comprends bien, il y a toujours une
militarisation du début de l'épidémie,
soit pour faire passer ça comme c'est
pas bon, soit un avis religieux, soit un
état contre un autre état pour le
déstabiliser et ainsi de suite. C'est
toujours l'occasion de récit
contradictoire parce que on il y a c'est
un événement politique, une épidémie
mais les médecins sont pas forcé
politiques. Alors, mais les récits sont
pas forcément Monseigneur Benzin ce
n'est pas un politique mais euh lui il a
il avait son histoire à raconter. Les
SALS sont pas des médecins, mais euh ils
ont été manipulés. Euh c'est pas
forcément euh les médecins. Alors les
médecins quand même quand ils mettent
leur grain de sel et qu' viennent de
très loin, euh on peut se méfier quand
même parce que dans la peste de
Marseille, il y a un autre discours,
c'est le médecin du régent s'appelle
Pierre Chirac. Et lui il va dire que de
toute façon tout ça c'est les foutises.
Il y a pas de peste à Marseille, c'est
juste les les dockers, les
les crocheteurs, ça s'appelle comme ça à
ce moment-là, qui récupèrent les
ballots, ben ils ont eu chaud, ils ont
eu froid, ils mangent pas bien, ils sont
morts de ça. Ils sont pas morts de la
peste, ils sont morts de d'une mauvaise
hygiène de vie.
Et donc
c'est le je sais pas à la bonne hauteur.
Non non, c'est parce que il y a le réel
qui est en train de s'endormir. Tu es en
train de le faire voyager entre les
mias. Le Pierre Chirac va raconter ça.
Et bien sur le cholé en Haïti, j'ai une
certaine dame, je donne les noms he si
vous voulez, elle s'appelle Rita Colwell
et elle va elle aussi expliquer
l'épidémie de choléra en Haïti depuis
son bureau dans le Maryland. Pas de
chance quand même. Très joli Maryland.
Oui, mais je sais pas. Est euh je sais
pas si je serais bien venu là-bas.
Depuis son bureau, elle va expliquer que
ça a incubé dans le delta du fleuveite
et c'est comme ça que l'épidémie a
démarré. Elle avait jamais fait de
terrain, elle y était pas allée et puis
ensuite elle a fait faire des
prélèvements et elle a publié des choses
qui étaient des articles sortis dans
PNAS. Je peux démontrer qu'il y a
falsification dans cet article comme
dans un article après qui a été publié
dans une autre revue qui essayait de
faire penser qu'il y avait eu une
inondation un peu avant le début de
l'épidémie. Donc il y a en plus une
intention de
tromper. Ça ça existe. Oui, c'est lourd.
Lourd la confraternité ça existe pas.
Ben, je suis pas c'est pas ma conseur
hein. Non, il y a pas et pas médecin
d'ailleurs. Euh mais c'est euh je suis
pas tenu par la confraternité d'accepter
les
mensonges. Donc en tout cas des
personnes qui à l'extérieur vont donner
des explications, faut s'en méfier
aussi. L'idéal c'est quand même d'aller
investiguer sur le terrain. C'est pas
toujours possible. J'aurais bien aimé
qu'une vraie mission investigue pour le
Covid investigue à la fois le marché et
le laboratoire mais en regardant les
cahiers de paillass en interrogeant les
chercheurs sans qu'il y ait toutes les
autorités autour toutes les autorités
autour évidemment c'est ça ça aurait été
une bonne chose en allant voir aussi
dans les grottes au sud de la Chine. Non
ils ont mis des portes blindées devant
on a plus le droit de je sais pas si les
portes étaient blindées. Il y avait
c'était pas possible d'y aller. Euh
quand il y a eu Ébola ou plus exactement
quand il y a eu Marbourg euh la fièvre
de Marbourg en Ouganda qu'on suspecté
des grottes, mais il y a quand même une
des gens qui sont venus de peu d'un peu
partout dans le monde, une une mission,
ils ont mis des tenues pour se protéger.
Ils sont allés dans ces grottes, ils
sont allés voir des euh s'il y avait des
chauves-souris qui mouraient. Ils en ont
trouvé plein et ils ont rampé dans des
endroits où il y avait des pyons, des
tics. Il y a énormément de tics et truc
comme ça. Fou les pyons. Oui, mais euh
je veux dire que quand on veut, on peut
faire l'investigation. Là, sur le sud de
la Chine, ça n'a pas eu lieu. Vous parle
et moi je suis partisan de ces
investigations pour qu'on fasse et qu'on
fasse la lumière sur les épidémies. Ce
sont des événements sanitaires, ce sont
aussi des événements politiques et comme
ce sont des événements politiques,
souvent il y a un barrage. Il faut faire
une commission d'enquête. Oui.
Sénatoriale. Euh alors en France, ça
vaut le coup. Moi, j'ai euh j'ai
consigné une tribune avec des
journalistes et des chercheurs et des
chercheurs tout à fait sérieux de
l'Institut Pasteur, de des virologues et
cetera. On on sait on a fini par
accepter de cosigner cette tribune qui
demandait d'abord à ce qu'il y ait une
commission d'enquête sur l'origine du
Covid que les Français s'y intéressent
parce que finalement les Allemands se
sont intéressés, les Anglais aussi, les
Américains avec la la commission du
Sénat, même si elle a été traversée par
des clivages politiques, il y a quand
même eu des auditions qui étaient
intéressantes.
En France, il y a rien vu et ça c'était
d'autant plus étonnant que la France
avait bah oui mais payu de l'Institut
Pasteur de Shanghaiï collabore une
coopération scientifique avec Shangï et
avec donc ça valait le coup de le faire.
Moi je pense que le le labo P4 de Ouran
n'a rien à voir avec la la pandémie. P3,
P2 quand même. Merde. Euh non mais le
P4, celui qui a été écrit euh construit
par la France, quand on regarde les
publications de l'équipe de Wouran de
virologie, jamais il travaillent en P4.
Pourquoi ? Ils disent "On travaille sur
des virus de chauve-souris, il y a pas
de
danger." Donc euh le c'est c'est pas lié
à ça. Par contre quand même cette
coopération devait aider à c'était une
coopération internationale justement
pour repérer les débuts d'épidémie, de
pandémie et cetera. Ça avait du sens. Et
là, tout d'un coup, ben il s'est rien
passé.
au moment où il aurait eu vraiment
besoin d'en mettre d'en faire quelque
chose, bah la France avait été plus ou
moins éjectée et finalement cet argent
n'a pas servi à ce qu'on soit
particulièrement informé sur le début de
l'épidémie. Mais c'est pas grave,
maintenant ils vont utiliser quelques
fonds spécial COVID pour faire autre
chose. Ah, je suis pas au courant.
Planter des fleurs ou acheter des
fusils. Je suis pas au courant. Euh,
revenons un petit peu sur les dogmes sur
les bâtons dans les roues des
médecins. On parlait d'éthiqu, la
maladie de l'IM, ça vous parle ? Oui,
mais j'ai pas j'ai pas suffisamment
approfondi pour pouvoir dire autre chose
que
les les changements écologiques qui ont
facilité la prolifération d'éthique qui
sont les vecteurs de la maladie de Lime
et en particulier dans le Connecticut.
Laingville du Connecticut. Euh donc
c'est peut-être une petite île aussi.
Je sais j'ai je sais pas là. Après moi
donc j'ai pas j'ai pas creusé le sujet.
Il y a tellement de sujets et je
voudrais parler que des choses sur
lesquelles vraiment je me suis vraiment
renseigné le plus à fond possible. Vous
parlez du One, euh le P2 le P3. Bah des
P2 des P3 il y en a partout. Et des P2
et des P3 qui font des recherches sur
gains de fonction il y en a beaucoup ou
pas ? Alors, c'était le centre au monde
qui faisait qui allait le plus loin avec
un un labo qui est à en en Caroline du
Nord à Chapellîille et il travaille
ensemble euh sur justement la
compréhension du euh du risque de euh de
transmission de virus de chauve-souris à
l'homme, le franchissement de la
barrière d'espèces. Et pour tester ça,
il y avait plusieurs systèmes qui
étaient mis en place. D'abord euh les
chercheurs américains de Chapel avaient
conçu un système pour fabriquer des
virus avec des virus chimériques,
c'est-à-dire des morceaux, mettre
ensemble des morceaux de virus pour
pouvoir en faire euh tester. Par
exemple, le la protéine spike, la
spicule qui qui sert à rentrer. Ils
avaient un modèle animal qui était des
souris qui à qui ils avaient dont ils
avaient modifié le génome pour qu'ils
aient un récepteur, le même récepteur
que l'homme pour ce ces spicules. Donc
c'est des souris humanisées avec des
récepteurs ACE2 qui ce qui est le ce
récepteur là. Et donc ils avaient ce
système et il venaient de les de
l'envoyer ces souris à CE2 humanisé
venaient d'être envoyé en 2018 à Ouran.
Donc la technologie était maîtrisée par
les gens d'Institut de virologie de
Wouran et un programme était en cours
dont la dernière année, je me souviens
plus du nom du programme, mais
maintenant je sais qu'ils vont trouver
le le ce ce programme. C'est pas des
fuses, hein, c'est un autre dont je
parle euh où le rapport a été communiqué
avec 2 ans de retard. Au lieu de le
rendre en 2019, ils l'ont rendu en 2021.
C'est ballot parce que dans ce rapport
ils expliquaient que selon les
assortiments qu'il faisaient enfin les
les bricolages qu'il faisait pas
utiliser assortiment parce que ça ça se
réfère au virus de la grippe mais
bricolages qui faisait euh entre les
protéines spike et le euh le squelette
viral, ils arrivaient à avoir des
mortalités chez les souris qui pouvaient
être très importantes. Donc une capacité
du virus qui pouvait être beaucoup plus
grande selon les la manière dont dont
c'était fait. Ce programme-là était
financé par le Anh et euh il y a eu il a
fait débat dans les auditions justement
aux États-Unis parce que euh Peter
d'Azac qui était le euh le coordonateur
de ces programmes avait juste oublié, il
avait pas réussi à transmettre le
dernier rapport et puis il avait oublié
de le faire et donc bon les élus
américains ont considéré qu'il les
prenait pour des consé
interdit de financement pour une période
de 5 ans. C'est pas très important par
rapport à ce qu'on peut suspecter comme
lien entre le ce type de recherche et la
pandémie, mais ça montre déjà qu'il y
avait qu'il y avait un problème. Donc
voilà les travaux qui étaient faits, des
travaux qui permettaient de d'un virus
inoffensif à obtenir quelque chose qui
avait toutes les capacités à rentrer
chez le chez la souris humanisée. qu'on
pouvait imaginer chez l'homme. Et à ça,
on ajoute donc le projet des fuses. Des
fuses, c'est comme désamorcer de en
anglais. Et euh et dans ce projet
d'effus, ils expliquaient comment ils
allaient éventuellement construire un
virus avec un site qui s'appelle un site
de clivage par les prothéases ou une
prothéase qu'on connaît, c'est la
furine. C'est une protéine qui détruit
les protéines et c'est une protéine
humaine. Et donc il voulait insérer ce
site à un endroit au milieu de la
protéine S2 entre S1 et S2 sur le la
protéine d'espue. Tap tap tap pas trop
sur la veste parce qu'il y a l'ingénieur
du son qui râle. Oui. D'accord. Bon il
fait un peu chaud. Non on va rentrer
dans des sujets voilà. Et donc on a
enfin quand même tout à l'heure j'ai
expliqué qu'on avait pas trouvé de
réservoir animal. Par contre, il y a
quand même des choses qui nous orient
vers quelque chose qui se serait passé
au laboratoire de virologie. Et pour
revenons 5 ans plus tard après le
confinement, les cafés assis, les cafés
debout avec les masques et puis pas les
non d'abord pas les masques parce que
soit-disant ça sert à rien puis les
masques après ça sert à quelque chose
après ça ser et puis machin et puis et
puis et puis tout en fait le le
le rétroédalage le pédalage le brassage
d'air chaud le brassage de vent et que
vas-y je te confine et que je te mets un
pass sanitaire mais vous inquiétez pas
ce sera pas un pass sanitaire et que on
sera pas obligé
de l'utiliser mais qu'on va quand même
l'utiliser et que il faut se vacciner,
il faut se vacciner, il faut se
vacciner, il faut se vacciner et puis on
a commandé 10 dose. Première
question, quand on on fait un conseil de
défense, on va faire une expérience de
pensée, vous et moi. Imaginez-vous, je
suis je suis le plus jeune professeur en
médecine en maladie infectieuse et
tropicale et que vous êtes un petit peu
de la partie. On se fait un conseil de
défense avec mon caméraman infirmière et
mon
réalisateur docteur. Je te vois bien
infirmière toi. Infirmier pardon. Et
qu'est-ce qu'un qu'est-ce qu'un
professeur en médecine pourrait faire
sans symbol infirmier ? D'ailleurs, on
fait une expérience de pensée, j'appelle
mes services de renseignement, je lui
dis "Bon alors les gars, on va se
réveiller un petit peu parce que vous
avez rien branlé. Euh j'ai reçu un
courrier le 31 décembre de l'ambassadeur
de France là-bas.
Il dit que bon, il tousse un peu, ils
font cacau. Vous allez un petit peu
essayer de réveiller vos sources sur
place, faire de la veille correcte et
des de justifier un peu votre salaire.
Et là, nos bons chiens
limier reviennent avec des infos du
genre "Bon patron
patron, il faisait un peu de
bricolage. Est-ce que chef de l'État
français France éternelle, Europe
éternelle, on commence à paniquer, on
fait des conseils de défense. Conseil de
défense qui dit conseil de défense dit
secret défense parce que quand même
c'est peut-être un virus militarisé par
les Chinois petit peut-être un petit peu
les Américains puis ils ont fait sortir
le démon de la boîte. On va expliquer
que les cafés assis les cafés debout que
les masques, les pas les masques parce
qu'on avait pas de masque parce qu'on
sait pas tenir notre logistique
proprement. Est-ce que l'État Est-ce que
les Français, malgré que ce soit la
ville, l'État et le pays de
pasteur, on s'est fait flouer et queils
ont surréagi parce qu'ils estimaient
qu'il y avait un coronavirus militarisé
qui pouvait faire une écatombe dans la
population et qu'on a dit au départ
c'est une petite grippe. J'ai pas de moi
j'ai aucun élément permettant de dire
que c'était militarisé. Non mais quand
je dis milit, je merci de la correction.
Quand je dis militariser, c'estàd que
une erreur dans une manipulation de
laboratoire, accident industriel. Un
accident. Oui, c'est c'est ce qu'on peut
imaginer, sachant que on n' jamais pu le
démontrer puisque il était pas question
d'étudier ce qui s'est passé dans le
laboratoire. En tout cas, pas au
regarder directement les cahiers de
paillasses, pas discuter tranquillement
et discrètement sans la présence de
nombreux témoins, y compris des
autorités politiques du pays, aux
discussions. Donc l'investigation de la
piste laboratoire n'a jamais été faite.
Pardon ?
et le rapport de
l'OMS qui a lieu donc un peu plus d'un
an après euh quand il explique que la
que la l'hypothèse du laboratoire est
très
improbable. On apprend quelques mois
après par une interview de de celui qui
a mené le l'investigation le qui a qui a
chapauté l'investigation qui s'appelle
Peter Ben en Amarek. il est danois et il
explique à la télévision danoise
quelques mois après que tout ça était le
fruit d'une négociation de la même
manière que dans la peste de Marseille,
il y a eu une négociation entre les
médecins montpelierin et les autorités
de la ville pour ne pas dire que c'était
la peste. De la même manière quand il y
a eu négociation sur le sur Haïti. Donc
c'est des choses qui existent.
Donc moi j'ai pas de j'ai pas plus
d'informations. Alors ça veut pas dire
qu'il y en a pas eu plus mais d'abord
moi j'étais pas dans les conseils de
défense ou quoi que ce soit. Je me suis
occupé de ce que je pouvais faire au
niveau de l'hôpital et j'étais dans les
cellules de crise de la PHP. Donc,
j'avais un certain nombre d'informations
liées à ça, mais euh jamais j'ai été
dans le dans le dans les ministère pour
participer aux discussions et je crois
pas que les scientifiques aient eu
beaucoup de eu ce conseil scientifique,
mais ils avaient donné un avis et puis
euh les politiques faisaient ce qu'ils
voulaient. Alors si si là là je vais
utiliser le jus de cerveau de
l'épidémiologiste
de de Colombo de terrain
d'enquêteur. Oui.
Si on fait un peu de rétroengineering
sur les mesures
sanitaires que l'État a appliqué sur la
population, on commence par les affiches
sanitaires A4 à Charles de Boule.
Pourquoi ça vous fait rire ? parce que
j'étais à ce moment-là, j'étais au début
du mois de mars, j'étais en République
démocratique du Congo travaillant sur le
sur le cholérage, je rentre, je
m'attendais à ce qui est c'était début
du mois de mars, peut-être le 6 mars ou
le 8 mars, je crois, gen contrôle de
température quand même. Ouais, un
minimum contrôle de température et
cetera. Et en fait non, il y avait
effectivement juste ces petites
affichettes et ça m'avait un petit peu
désarçonné, on va dire et très vite, je
vais demander à participer à la cellule
de crise de de mon hôpital, à la pitié
salpétrière et je sentais que même s'il
y avait une montée en progression, elle
était un peu trop sereine, un peu trop
plan quelque part, il voyait pas
arriver le tsunami qui était en train
d'arriver. Et
c'est le 6 mars, je crois où le le
président de la République sort, va au
théâtre et dit aux français "Vivez
normalement, il y a pas de problème." Il
donc il y a il y a pas de prise de
conscience. Alors Agnès Busin dit
qu'elle qu'elle a alerté, moi je veux
bien la croire mais jusqu'à preuve du
contraire, moi je préfère croire. Mais
en tout cas, elle dit qu'elle a qu'elle
a elle a alerté, mais en tout cas dans
la politique, il y a vraiment jusqu'à
preuve du enfin, il se passe rien. Et
c'est vraiment quelques jours avant le
premier tour des municipales que ça
commence à frémir, à se réveiller. Et
c'est là que je on a nous au niveau de
la PHP une un weekend extrêmement actif
où les épidémiologistes, les
modélisateurs, les réanimateurs sont
convoqués.
Ah ben c'est au mois de mars. C'est
c'est
le 13 et le 14 mars. Le 14 mars, c'est
un samedi. Le 13, moi j'ai une
discussion avec le Martin Hirche
justement.
J'arrive enfin à son bureau pour pouvoir
lui expliquer mon inquiétude et pourquoi
j'étais inquiet. Et il capte bien. Et
ensuite, mais en fait la même chose
s'était passée de jours avant à l'Élysée
avec les collègues de pasteurs qui sont
venus quand même alerter et c'est là que
il y a une prise de conscience. C'est
très tardif.
Alors nous nous on a une position un peu
bâard là-dedans. Oui. C'est c'est feu
Montparin était le plus jeune professeur
en virologie pas en virologie en maladie
infectieuse et
tropicale. Donc il a bossé sur quelques
petits dossiers. Donc on a été très on a
été sensibilisé très tôt à ce type de
propagation de se laver les mains
correctement et depuis tout tout petit.
Et puis on est un peu bâtard aussi,
c'est on a le meilleur service de
renseignement du monde. C'est-à-dire
qu'on a des gens à nous, des copains
partout dans le monde. Ah oui, le donc
nous la communauté des hackers, notre
communauté pas que des hackers mais à il
y a beaucoup de mecs qui travaillent
dans la tech et clairement on avait des
gens sur place entre le 15 et le 17
janvier, on avait des mecs sur place qui
nous tenaient au courant que ça partait
en sucette façon Dustin Hoffman, le film
alerte.
La question que je me pose c'est alors
la même chose
hein. Montoyen avait des collègues qui
qui étaient directeur médical de crise
de la PHP avait des collègues à Bouran
il les connaissait il avait le même type
d'information. Donc ces informations
arrivaient par des canofician
a faisait passer les informations d'une
façon non officielle. D'ailleurs, il y
en a un qui qui a mal terminé. Oui,
c'est curieux pour une une personne de
34 ans, mais on le savait pas à
l'époque. Euh à 34 ans, on meurt pas du
Covid et il est mort du
Covid. Je trouve simplement que c'est
curieux le c'est ce collègue Oftalmo.
Oui. Quand quand on a normalement de
l'information de terrain, des
informations de collègues, des
informations de communauté et que on
essaie de tirer l'alarme, il s'est passé
quoi ? a tiré à vue sur tous les gens
qui essayaient de dire attention ça
peut-être sorti d'un
labatoire les journalistes foncé
là-dedans. Quel a été le rôle des
acadées de médecine ? Alors moi pour
sonner l'alerte, ce que c'est à la fin
du mois de janvier que le euh l'idée que
ça peut être un labo commence à vraiment
euh percoller percoller. Oui. à ce
moment-là, d'abord parce que la séquence
est disponible et parce que dans le
papier qui décrit la séquence, ils
oublient de parler de ce site furine qui
n'existe pas chez les autres euh virus
proches, les sarbécovirus, les virus qui
donnent qui avaient donné le premier
SARS et les virus apparentés qu'on
trouve chez les chauves-souris.
Maintenant, on en a vu des centaines. Ce
site furine est une chose unique. Je
vous rappelle qu'il y avait ce programme
d'effus mais on le savait pas ça. On
connaissait pas des fuses. On il avait
pas été exumé. Mais quand même ce
site-là avait interpellé en particulier
des collègues virologues à Marseille,
Bruno Canaré Étienne de de Croly et qui
avait quand même euh vu ça. Et puis aux
États-Unis, c'était la même chose. Ils
ont vu ça et ça a commencé à discuter et
effectivement euh
là on sait que c'est par les par les
auditions, on sait que un certain nombre
de scientifiques euh se sont émus de de
ce cet aspect particulier du virus, de
ce site tout à fait particulier. Il y a
des mails qui ditent "Mais ça peut pas
être naturel."
euh des mails signés par exemple Robert
Gary. Et Robert Gary, c'est intéressant
parce que il va être le dernier auteur,
donc l'auteur seior en quelque sorte
d'un article qui sera extrêmement
diffusé qui plus tard dira que ça ne
pouvait pas être un virus fait en
laboratoire passant par un laboratoire,
c'était complètement exclu. Pourtant, au
même moment, il disait que pour lui, il
comprenait pas comment il y a ce site
furine autrement que de cette parce
queil sortait d'un laboratoire. Il le
disait à des collègues. Donc Christian
Andersen, premier auteur de la même
publication qui lui aussi se posait
énormément de questions. Donc eux, des
chercheurs ont tiré la sonnette d'alarme
en France, aux États-Unis, en
Angleterre. Et ça, pour ce qui est les
États-Unis et l'Angleterre, ça a généré
des conférences téléphoniques, des
discussions dont on a les échos à droite
à gauche et euh ces discussions ont
abouti à la publication d'un article qui
disait que ça pouvait pas être un truc
de laboratoire alors que parallèlement
et encore après la publication, les
mêmes auteurs se posaient toujours des
questions en privé. En public, il
disaient ça pouvait pas être un
laboratoire en privé. continuer à se
poser des questions. On a les mails, on
sait que ça s'est passé comme ça.
Parallèlement, j'ai parlé déjà de Peter
d'Azdac qui est
un donc qui coordonnait des recherches
entre les États-Unis et l'Institut de
virologie de Wouran entre autres sur
justement ses recherches sur la capacité
des virus à franchir la
la barrière d'espèce.
Et on va avoir ce ce cette personne-là
qui va mobiliser des gens autour de lui
pour faire un article dans la revue de
Land 7 disant que c'est une théorie
complotiste que de d'imaginer que ce
soit quelque chose laboratoire et que
les collègues de Chinois sont soumis à
des pression terribles à cause de
vilains méchants qui qui les accusent
d'avoir été en en cause. Ce qui est
intéressant, c'est que en fait, il va
écrire alors dans les cignataires, il y
a Rita Colwell parce qu'elle appartient
à la même organisation et il va écrire
justement à Rita Colwell et à d'autres,
il va dire on va être très discret sur
mon mon rôle dans ce truclà parce que il
faut pas qu'on qu'on accuse de de faire
ça pour d'autres raisons pour que ce
soit vu comme un truc politique. On va
essayer de montrer ça comme une une
opinion spontanée des chercheurs. C'est
ce qui est dans les mails. Et puis
encore, il y a un troisème article. Lui,
il est complètement téléguidé par deux
chercheurs chinois à Shanghai qui vont
embarquer des chercheurs américains et
les complètement les embobiner. Et
ensuite, on a là encore enfin chinois de
d'orig euh une revue de Shanghaiï, des
chercheurs chinois qui sont en contact
avec cette revue mais qui sont aux
États-Unis qui vont embarquer des
collègues pour avoir plus de signatures
et qui vont les embarquer alors que ces
gens, ses collègues comprennent pas que
c'était téléguidé, que c'était déjà
décidé par par une revue et et ces
échanges sont vraiment
complètement euh
euh édifiants sur tout ce qui s'est
passé. Donc, il y a eu une opération
pour que on donne l'impression que la
communauté scientifique avait conclu
l'affaire. Ça ne pouvait pas être une
histoire de laboratoire, c'était quelque
chose de complètement naturel. Ça c'est
nouveau. Tiens, ça c'est une innovation.
c'est cette entente d'un certain nombre
de chercheurs pour casser le débat et
permettre de de dire ça ne peut être
qu'une hypothèse de complotiste. La
vraie la vérité c'est le marché. Et
depuis alors ces auteurs-là de cette
première publication dans Nature
Médecine qui s'appelle Proxime à
l'origine euh de du Covid euh ont
intervenus x fois dans différentes
publications pour ramener de l'eau à
leur moulin et expliquer que tout ça
avait commencé au marché. On n toujours
pas la preuve que ça a commencé au
marché. On n pas non plus la preuve que
ça a commencé dans le laboratoire
puisquon n pas pu enquêter dans le
laboratoire. Sur l'architecture du
virus. Il y a quand même un fait un un
fait sous qui nous pose des questions.
Le site Furine. Alors ça fait on peut on
nous dit c'est une coïncidence. Alors
c'est une
coïncidence. Des pandémies à
coronavirus, il y en a pas tant que ça.
Passer deux trois quoi même. Euh il y en
a peut-être une en
18 au 20e siècle. On a pas eu. Il y a eu
le premier SARS mais c'était pas une
pandémie. Bon, on a s'est fait un peu
peur quand même et c'est d'ailleurs les
recherches ont été justifiées par ce
premier SARS en 2002 mais c'était pas
une pandémie et donc finalement c'est
pas quelque chose aussi commun.
Pourtant, elle arrive en 2019, donc
juste au moment où effectivement tous
les éléments sont là pour mener cette
recherche qui est décrite dans des fuses
non financé par les Américains, ça c'est
clair. Euh, elle arrive dans la ville où
cette
recherche allait être menée. Alors
certains disent ouais mais ça devait
être mené aux États-Unis mais quand on
voit les drafts du du projet il est
indiqué que ça peut la une partie des
des manipes allaiit se faire en Chine
mais on allait pas trop insister dessus
parce que sinon ça allait faire un peu
peur au donateur au bailleurs de fond.
Donc là, c'est au bon endroit, c'est au
bon moment et c'est le portrait robot du
virus avec son site furine à l'endroit
où il était prévu et ressemblant à un
site furine humain et pas un site furine
qu'on va trouver dans la nature sur
d'autres d'autres virus. Ça peut être
une coïncidence maintenant. C'est quand
même ça plus le fait qu'on a jamais
trouvé l'ô intermédiaire, ça fait
beaucoup à mon sens. et que les Chinois
mis des portes blindées et que les
Chinois aient retiré des bases de virus
euh juste avant et que et que et que et
que et que et que euh donc on a on a
traité ça
euh le Ah si, il y a un truc important
qu'il faudrait qu'on dans oublié le la
chose, c'est les deux découvertes
biologiques qui ont changé le monde, les
microbes et l'ADN, le breuage de
certaines choses aussi, ça peut être
intéressant. ce qui ce qui est important
pour que on comprenne parce que
finalement c'est pas un épiphénomène
mais c'est une tendance lourde, une
tendance
globale. On on a compris l'impact de la
découverte des microbes enfin du rôle
des microbes. Et bien faut qu'on
comprenne aussi alors ça c'est après la
pandémie de grippe espagnole, la
recherche de la de la cause de la grippe
espagnole a permis de trouver
des a permis de Je vous laisse terminer
vos trucs. Non non non, c'est la cuisine
cadr qui veut parler au réal parler
derrière. D'accord. Euh
donc à les chercheurs pendant la
pandémie de grippe ont essayé de
comprendre quelle était la cause. Ils
sont partis sur une mauvaise piste sur
une bactérie qu'ils avaient ils
appelaient basilus influencé qu'on
appelle maintenant hémophilus influencé.
Et bon ça les a amené quand même à
découvrir les
antibiotiques, la cause de la grippe
mais il y a une découverte qui est très
importante, c'est la découverte de l'ADN
ou plus exactement du rôle de l'ADN.
Euh et ça c'est on la doit à Oswald
d'Avri qui s'aperçoit que
finalement l'information génétique, ce
qui rend par exemple une bactérie qui
s'appelle le pneumocoque virulent est
une information qui est transmise par
l'ADN. On passe sur la manière dont il a
démontré ça, sur les expérimentations
qui ont été faites avant et qu'il a
complété, mais ça permet de de trouver
le la cause
de euh ça permet de ils font ils bougent
dans tous les sens, donc j'ai du mal à
me concentrer. Euh je suis facilement
des Ça permet de trouver que la vie Oui.
Oui.
vie et le code enfin le ce qui transmet
les informations relatives à la vie,
c'est dans l'ADN. Donc c'est une
découverte extraordinairement
importante au moins aussi importante que
la découverte des microbes et c'est lié
aux recherches de microbiologie après la
pandémie de grippe espagnole. Et
derrière qu'est-ce qu'on a ? Une fois
qu'on a l'ADN et qu'on sait à quoi ça
sert, on va concentrer les recherches
là-dessus. Et c'est moi je je revu il y
a pas très longtemps le film Openheimer
et une fois qu'on sait ça, on le sait
pour toujours. Une sait une fois qu'on
sait le pouvoir de la bombe atomique, on
le sait pour toujours. Et le spectre de
la bombe atomique est toujours là. Et
bien l'ADN, c'est la même chose. Le
secret de la vie, le le génome avec ces
ce code génétique qui va expliquer
comment on fabrique les protéines,
comment les cellules se reproduisent,
les bactéries, les virus, les êtres
humains. On apprend à faire ça, on
apprend à faire des choses qui sont très
bien comme les tests pour faire
l'identification. Puis on apprend aussi
à reconstituer des virus à partir
simplement de prélèvement congelés dans
le grand nord. On a en Alaska chez les
inuites par exemple. Euh d'ar avec la
grippe espagnole. Exactement avec le
fait de ressusciter en 2005 ressusciter
le virus de la grippe espagnole pour
voir un peu pour l'étudier en
laboratoire. C'est sympa mais c'est
quand même un peu dangereux cette
histoire là. On apprend aussi, ça c'est
en 2017, à refaire un virus encore plus
compliqué qui un virus de la variole
équine.
C'est bien, c'est c'est une bonne idée,
mais en même
temps c'est fait uniquement à partir de
séquence. Donc avec des choses sur
ordinateur, il y a plus de matériel
biologique et puis on fait synthétiser
les brins d'ADN, on les reconstruit et
toute la méthode est décrite. Si vous
voulez vous ne vous gênez pas, vous avez
plus vous avez le mode d'emploi. C'est
pour le la variole équine mais on peut
très bien adapter ça pour la variole qui
a été éradiquée.
On apprend aussi à passer d'un virus
H5N1 sur des furets et puis en faire un
virus donc depuis d'un virus de d'oiseau
à un virus de mammifère, d'un virus de
voie digestive à un virus des voies
respiratoires et ça aussi ça met un peu
des mois quand même sur dans la
communauté scientifique. Et puis à ces
expériences effectivement sur les virus
chimériques fait soit à Chapel, soit à
Ouran où on fabrique des coronavirus qui
sont capables de pénétrer des
cellules
humanisées. Et tout ça se fait
finalement dans une espèce d'ambiance où
les
scientifiques ont pas tout à fait
conscience un qu'il peut y avoir des
accidents. Alors des accidents, il y en
a eu. Euh il y a eu une une épidémie de
grippe rien que le fait de conserver des
des virus de la grippe. Il y a eu une
épidémie de grippe en une pandémie même
euh en 1977 qui démarre soit en Chine,
soit en Russie. On l'appelle la grippe
russe. On sait pas si elle est russe ou
pas.
Mais maintenant, on sait que ce virus
était exactement le même qu'un virus qui
avait disparu 20 ans après, d'ailleurs
descendant de la grippe espagnole.
Donc en 1957, il a disparu. Il réapparut
en
1977 sans avoir muté depuis
donc congelé quoi pendant 20 ans. Et ça
maintenant, on a on sait pas comment ça
s'est passé, si c'est une expérience de
vaccination qui a foiré, si c'est un
labo dans un congélateur qu'on a
ressorti mais on a eu ça et on sait pas
combien il y a eu de morts mais ça a été
quelque chose une pandémie de grippe qui
surtout toucher les personnes jeunes
puisque les personnes plus âgées après
de 20 20 25 ans et bien avait déjà connu
ce virus avant. Et puis on a aussi un
accident assez
extraordinaire qui est quand on a un
laboratoire il y a des contrôles
qualité, c'est-à-dire on va recevoir des
prélèvements qu'on doit analyser, on
doit rendre le résultat exact et si on
n'y arrive pas, ben faut qu'on se pose
des questions sur la manière de faire.
Et bien là, un laboratoire de référence
a envoyé à 3700 autres laboratoires aux
États-Unis et un peu en Europe. Un virus
qui est un virus de la grippe vivant,
H2N2 qui avait disparu 36 ans
auparavant.
Il y a pas eu d'accident mais il y
aurait pu y avoir dès lors que on a on
manipule des virus, on les ressuscite,
on les fait passer d'un endroit à
l'autre, on les congèle, on les
décongèle, on expose les gens à un
risque d'accident. Et ce risque
d'accident, c'est pas comme avec la
peste ou la variole ou il y a des les
techniciens ou les biologistes vont
mourir ou la photographe à Birmingham
qui meurt euh de la de la variole, la
dernière personne qui meurt. Non, là
c'est un virus qui peut ensuite diffuser
dans la population parce qu'il est très
contagieux et qui peut provoquer des
pandémies. Donc ça, on a déjà
l'expérience de ces trucs-là. Et puis on
a parlé de la guerre de euh de Pontiac
avec les couvertures, les Mongols avec
leur tribucher et la peste. On a parlé
de l'unité 731 avec les Japonais. Euh on
n' pas encore parlé de la guerre qui
s'est passée entre les Japonais et les
Américains à propos du paludisme dans le
dans le Pacifique. Mais en fait euh
quand on est dans une dans un conflit et
personne ne peut dire qu'on ne sera plus
jamais dans un conflit. Je crois même
qu'il y en a des conflits en ce moment
si j'ai bien compris. Quand on est dans
un conflit, rien n'empêche euh que
quelqu'un décide d'utiliser une arme
biologique. On peut absolument pas dire
ça n'arrivera jamais. Et c'est d'autant
plus difficile à dire que c'est de plus
en plus facile à faire parce que
entre-temps, ben on a appris à éditer un
génome, à le fabriquer. Crisper, oui,
bien sûr. Euh à fabriquer des virus, les
ressusciter et les recettes sont
publiées, les recettes sont
accessibles. Moi, ça me fait flipper un
peu. Est-ce que ça peut tomber dans la
main de groupes terroristes ou ça peut
tomber dans la main de groupes religieux
terroristes ou d'États béliqueux
? Bah c'est c'est dans le domaine
public.
Alors après effectivement quand on
commande une séquence d'ADN à des boîtes
qui ont pignon sur rue euh il vérifie de
ce qu'on
commande à des boîtes pignons sur rue
fabriquer de l'ADN euh s'il y a des
boîtes privées qui font d'autres peuvent
très bien le faire. Donc c'est pas c'est
plus un obstacle.
Euh après le le seul truc c'est de se
dire "Ouais mais qui prendrait les
risques de contaminer le la population
du monde d'abord ça reviendrait vers
eux. Alors sauf si on est assez organisé
pour avoir les traitements voilà
l'asymétrie qu'on avait avant
l'asymétrie qu'on avait euh dans la les
guerres contre les Indiens en Amérique
euh où on avait euh euh des gens
immunisés versus des gens non immunisés.
des traitements, les vaccins peuvent
permettre cette asymétrie. Donc un
traitement efficace plus un ou un vaccin
plus un virus qui diffuse, ça peut
arriver. Alors, il nous reste à espérer
que partout dans l'humanité, les gens
seront bien se tenir et se dire ils vont
pas vouloir refaire ce que euh les
Anglais ont fait aux Indiens d'Amérique,
ce que les Mongols ont fait au Génois à
CAFA ou euh d'autres d'autres choses qui
sont
arrivées, les Japonais aux Chinois,
on parle des
vaccins et des anti-vaccins.
Alors, on peut parler des de l'histoire
des vaccins et des anti-vaccins. Ça euh
vaccin, c'est Ah, juste avant qu'on
parle de vaccin et d'antivaccin, euh je
me rappelle ce que vous avez dit il y a
quelques minutes sur le fait que le
dogme, la propagande dans un sens ou
dans un autre. Est-ce que vous vous
rappelez du prix Nobel de médecine le
professeur Montagier qui avait dit à
l'époque avant de canner euh on a un
problème avec l'architecture du vaccin ?
On voit que c'est des bouts de du virus
du virus, pardon. Merci. Euh, on a un
problème avec le virus. Euh, c'est des
bouts qui ressemblent à ça, c'est des
bouts qui ressemblent à ça. Et il a été
complètement vilipandé. Il avait tort.
Il avait tort. Il avait tort. En tout
cas, mais il parlait de Il disait que
c'était fait avec des morceaux de virus
du sida et en fait non, il y avait pas
euh les par hasard, il peut y avoir des
petits bouts de séquence, mais ça
pouvait totalement être lié au hasard.
Euh forcément avec quatre lettres et
certains mots finissent par se
ressembler s'ils sont très courts.
Le fait qu'il qu'il ait été vilipandé à
l'époque h c'était parce qu'il s'était
planté ou c'est parce qu'il y avait un
rouleau compresseur qui poussait
l'opinion publique vers un sens ? Il
devait y avoir les deux mais en tout cas
il s'était planté.
les vaccins, les anti-vaccins. Alors ça
c'est une histoire, c'est intéressant
parce que alors il y a une maladie qui
faisait énormément de morts. On a vu
l'impact qu'elle a pu avoir dans les
Amériques, mais au 17e siècle, il y a eu
le le virus de la variole a tendance à à
changer de virulence à certains moments.
Et là, il y a un un moment où il est
devenu beaucoup plus virulent. Et alors,
il a il tué en particulier les têtes
couronnées. Pourquoi ? Parce que dans la
l'aristocratie, il y avait peut-être
moins de risque de se d'être contaminé
pendant l'enfance. Et donc, quand ils
accédaient au pouvoir, les monarques
pouvaient être tués. Et euh Louis XV,
par exemple, en France, mais plein de
plein d'autres monarques ont été tués
par la variole à ce moment-là. Et euh
donc ils ont et c'est l'aristocratie en
Angleterre qui a importé une technique
qui était la
variation. C'est euh euh
le madame Montag Vortley Montag qui
était la femme d'un ambassadeur anglais
en Turquie qui a amené cette truc de la
variation. Elle-même, elle avait eu la
variole, son frère était mort. Elle
avait perdu sa beauté à cause de la
variole et donc elle avait réussi à
convaincre, y compris la princesse de de
Gale, donc euh les futurs héritiers du
trône d'Angleterre euh d'être variisé.
Euh donc c'était une quelque chose qui
était
relativement relativement sérieux quand
même parce que fallait être isolé parce
que sinon on filait la variole autour de
soi et il y avait quand même des risques
de dessè même si c'était beaucoup moins
que la variole elle-même peut-être 1 %
versus 10 ou 20 % mais enfin quand même
c'est on on donne un on inocule la
variole à quelqu'un à travers la peau
activement et la personne meurt. On se
sent un peu tout quand même. Donc c'est
dans ce contexte là qu'un médecin
anglais Géner
va constater, il est en zone rurale que
les les femmes qui traient les les
vaches, de temps en temps, les vaches
font une forme ressemblant à la variole
et elles ont des lésions sur des pucules
sur les mains qui ressemblent aux
pucules à
vari surtout quand arrive une épidémie
de
varien. Il voit ça, il est pas le
premier à le voir mais il en il fait des
essais. Il va filer ça à son jard au
gamin de son jardinier. Il vaah à la
limite puisqu'on faisait la variation,
c'était plutôt cool de commencer par lui
donner un truc moins moins dangereux et
puis ensuite était au courant de ce
qu'il allait prendre le gamin ? Je suis
pas au courant. Enfin, j'ai pas le
détail si ça s'appelle comment quand on
est médecin ? C'est un consentement
averti. Oui. Alors, je sais pas
peut-être peut-être pas. On est on est
faut pas faire d'accronisme, on est au
18e siècle et en plus on est à une
époque où la variation se fait. Donc, on
inocule la variole avec le vrai virus de
la variole. Donc là, il lui inocule
quelque chose qui est beaucoup moins
dangereux qui est le virus de la variole
de la vache vaca.
En fait, il va appeler il va lui donner
le nom de vaccin, le virus de la vache.
Et ensuite, il lui il lui fait une
variation un peu après et le gamin se
porte comme le pont neuf. Donc il
réessaye. Alors il essaie de publier, il
se fait jeter hein. Génère s'est fait
jeter dans le lancette. Non, c'est il y
avait pas le lancette à l'époque. Euh
mais il se fait jeter et il finit par
euh consolider sa démonstration, le
tester sur d'autres personnes et euh
publier un compte d'auteur. Et
finalement son truc prend et
effectivement ça va écrouler l'incidence
de la variole dans les pays où la
vaccination va se faire. Donc on a
quelque chose qui marche bien, sauf que
génère il pousse un peu le bouchon trop
loin parce qu'il dit quelqu'un qui est
vacciné va être immunisé à vie. En fait,
il va y avoir des gens qui une fois
vaccinés quelques années après ou quel
10 ou 20 ans après vont refaire une
variole. Donc on va dire mais il a
menti, il a juste un peu trop survendu
son vaccin et puis c'est un vaccin, faut
faire gaffe parce que on passe de bras
en bras euh et donc on peut passer aussi
avec la vaccine de la syphilis par
exemple. Et donc là, il y a eu des
drames des gamins qui sont morts et des
morts collectives lié à la syphilis. Et
ça, ça a fait des problèmes. Donc ça a
pu aider. Mais le mouvement antivax, il
s'est d'abord nourri de ceux qui
faisaient la
variation parce qu'ils perdaient leur
leur business. Et donc cit quoi leur
business ? et ben c'était de d'inoculer
la variole mais avec le virus de la
variole, pas celui de la
vache. Donc c'était plus dangereux et
cetera. Mais euh alors il y a il y a des
caricatures euh en disant que euh les
personnes deviennent euh moitié vache,
moitié homme. Euh qu'un gamin vacciné se
met à se comporter comme un un taureau
en furie en rentrant à la et donnant des
coups de tête partout et les choses
comme ça et des caricatures montrant des
cornes qui poussent. C'est et donc si on
a vraiment ce système là qui se met euh
en place et ça finalement tout ce qu'on
va trouver dans le le discours antivax
récent, le côté naturel, le côté divin,
le côté euh enfin t tous les tous ces
arguments, on les a déjà et on les a
pour une maladie qui tuait quand même un
enfant sur 10 à l'époque.
Donc c'est pour ça que il faut quand
même prendre un peu de recul par rapport
à ce discours
antivax. Il faut écouter parce que il y
a il y a eu un problème il y a eu un
problème de communication sur la
dangerosité du vaccin qui a été
sous-estimé sur ça. Je parle du vaccin
Covid là maintenant sur la vache mince.
Alors plus de la vache et et sur son
efficacité qui été nous a été vendue
comme très élevé dans des études euh des
études
publiées. C'est pas la rumeur hein qui
disait ça, c'était dans des études
simplement avec le temps l'efficacité à
vite diminué et ça le labor les
laboratoires qui vendaient le médicament
sont pas trop ventés. les académies de
médecine au milieu de tout ça, le
consentement éclairé du patient. Ah, on
était c'est c'est quoi ce délire là ?
parce que le attention on était en
période d'épidémie, il y avait donc il y
a eu différentes manière d'aborder dans
l'histoire de la vaccination en par
exemple pour la variole différentes
manières d'aborder selon les endroits,
selon les contextes et des fois c'était
très très serré hein et d'autrefois
beaucoup plus laxiste.
Ça c'est plus de la médecine, c'est de
la décision politique. Et ça ça reste de
la décision politique parce que au 18e
siècle, mais au 18e siècle, au 19e
siècle ou 20e siècle, la décision
d'imposer un vaccin ou pas est une
décision politique parce que elle rend
elle prend en compte non seulement le
côté santé publique, mais elle prend
aussi en compte le côté économique, le
côté sécurité intérieure. Rappelons
aussi que la France a perdu la guerre
contre la Prusse en partie à cause d'une
épidémie de vari. Ces militaires étaient
mal vaccinés alors que les militaires
prussiens étaient bien vaccinés. Et on a
eu 25000 à peu près 25000 morts de
varies et donc 120 et quelques soldats
au tapis par la
maladie
versus quelques centaines de morts côté
prussien. Quand on a 25000 morts et
100000 personnes au tapis et qu'on fait
la guerre, on est moins en forme quand
même. Et euh la la Prusse a euh alors ça
ça a eu plein de conséquences, hein. la
commune de Paris, le siège de Paris, euh
la constitution de d'une Allemagne
forte, la prise de l'Alsace et de la
Lorine et puis la revanche avec la
guerre 14 et puis la revanche de la
revanche. Enfin, on est quand même
rentré dans un cycle de guerre mais au
départ le lors de des premiers
affrontements entre les Français et les
Prussiens, la variole tapait de manière
asymétrique. Donc cette asymétrie liée
maintenant au vaccin, cette asymétrie,
elle reste un facteur essentiel de la
géopolitique et des stratégies, y
compris en période de conflit et surtout
en période de conflit. Je voudrais qu'on
revienne au au vaccin Covid, au
consentement
éclairé, à la décision politique. Est-ce
qu'il y en a à découler ? C'est-à-dire
le café assis, le café debout,
faites-vous vacciner. Oui. Et ainsi de
suite. Tout ira bien. C'est un peu une
manie quand même. Vous êtes vacciné,
vous irez faire des câlins, à papi à
mamie et et ce ser et ce sera bien. Il
faut tout il faut il faut protéger les
plus vulnérables. Et si vous êtes pas
vacciné, bah vous comprenez, vous allez
tuer les
vieux. C'est compliqué. C'est un choix.
C'est un choix. Ça a donné comme
conséquence un énorme mouvement de
défiance d'une population. Euh la
défiance, c'est pas lié que à ça. Euh
l'histoire les masques, pas les masques,
ça a commencé quand même euh très fort.
La communauté médicale, ils sont pas
foutus de la gueule de du pouvoir
politique quand ils ont entendu ça.
Je sais pas, moi ça m'a en tout cas euh
cette histoire de masque, je parle des
masques là quand on s'est aperçu que euh
on recevait des malades à la pitié
salpétrière et qu'on les renvoyait chez
eux enfin dans le métro et cetera et
cetera sans sans masque sans Mais oui
mais c'était comme ça et impossible.
Alors, on avait fini par com le randonné
euh au moment où vous partez et puis je
me suisau, je suis Ben oui, bien sûr. et
je suis allé dans une pharmacie. Sous le
manteau, je déconne pas. Sous le
manteau. Oui. Ben, on leur donnait mais
les euh la directrice de l'hôpital
savait. Enfin, il a c'est pas euh on
allé dans une dans une pharmacie et
effectivement il était impossible
d'acheter des masques. Il y avait même
pas question de faire des masques en
tissu ou quoi que ce soit. Enfin, c'est
ça servait à rien. Enfin, ça servait à
rien. Alors, le gouvernement voulait les
garder pour l'hôpital, les personnes euh
les soignants mais pas pour les malades.
Et là, moi ça me posa un problème et
c'est à ce moment-là qu'on a démarré le
programme Covissan qui accompagner c'est
c'est d'abord à partir des gens qui
étaient aux urgences et des équipes
venaient contacter enfin rentrer en
contact avec ces personnes au moment où
elles partaient pour leur fournir de
quoi se protéger, leur expliquer comment
se protéger, leur proposer
éventuellement de les accompagner
jusqu'au domicile pour aider à
s'organiser dans la vie à l'intérieur du
domicile. de manière totalement
volontaire, ça s'était pas du tout
imposé et qui était l'idée était que ces
personnes-là ne soient enfin qui avaient
pas envie de contaminer leur entourage
puisse s'organiser pour ne pas
contaminer. D'ailleurs, on a tous fait
un peu ça. On tous moi j'ai été
contaminé par le Covid en allant en
Guyane, en rentrant chez moi, ben
effectivement, on a fait chambre à part,
c'était l'été, les fenêtres étaient
ouvertes et cetera. J'avais pas envie de
contaminer ma femme à ce moment-là. Donc
euh c'est quelque chose qui était tout à
fait logique. Le fait de faire repartir
les gens sans masque, sans conseil et
cetera, je trouvais que c'était pas euh
pas pertinent. Au niveau de la pitié de
salpétrière, on l'a fait, on l'a étendu
à plusieurs sites, une dizaine de sites
en région parisienne et puis quand la
vague a décru, tout ça a été oublié et
ça n'intéressait plus les politiques et
ils ont laissé euh ils ont laissé
tomber. La deuxème vague est arrivée, on
est reparti à zéro
sur la défiance. Bah ça ça fait de la
défiance. Ça ça c'est de l'incohérence.
les discours, les masques, ça sert à
rien. Puis les masques, c'est
obligatoire sur un temps très court.
C'est pas prudent de de porter un tel
discours. Et ça, ça on montre que ça
montre qu'il y a du tâtonnement. Il vaut
mieux dire quand on sait pas que d'avoir
cette affirmation et puis ensuite redire
de manière tout aussi péremptoire le
contraire. Et ça ça a fait une première
défiance. Sur le vaccin, il y a eu de la
défiance et puis il y a quand même ce
mouvement antivax. Enfin, globalement,
les gens se sont vaccinés euh au début.
Après, quand il y a eu le premier
problème avec le vaccin d'Astrazeneca,
quel type de problème ? Bah, c'est les
personnes jeunes et en particulier à
l'hôpital, on avait les le tout le
personnel soignant qui est plutôt jeune
qu'on a qui a été vacciné et qui était
vacciné avec ce ce vaccin. Ils étaient
quand même mis euh vraiment à plat par
le par le vaccin. Il y a eu des des
myocardites, il y a eu des couleurs
précordiales avec.
Oui, il y a eu des choses comme ça.
Après, c'est moins mon domaine, donc je
vais pas aller plus loin, mais je me
souviens que c'était un problème et ce
vaccin, il a été arrêté rapidement.
Donc, il y a quand même eu des airements
et ça a effectivement diminué la
confiance. C'est-à-dire que quand on a
infirmé d'une façon très péremptoire
qu'il y avait des milliers d'années de
recul parce que on a vacciné x personnes
et qu'on est donc cumulé, ça donnait du
recul sur les l'efficacité ou les effets
secondaires du vaccin et qu'on pouvait
se vacciner les yeux fermés, c'était un
consentement averti, un consentement
éclairé où c'était vaccine-toi parce que
on est en train de se chier dessus et on
sait pas où ça va nous emmener. Ça va
tuer l'économie, ça va tuer notre
électoral vieux. C'est une présentation
un petit peu caricaturale caricaturale
he ça fait pas des milliers d'années. On
on savait que alors le vaccin
d'Astrazenca c'était pas un vaccin à Ren
et donc celui-là c'est celui qui a posé
le plus de problèmes. Vaccin AERN chacun
savait qu'on avait peu
d'expérience et le les la les variations
du virus. On avait aussi très peu
d'expérience quand donc sur l'efficacité
euh on avait euh la première publication
était très positive et puis après on a
peut-être les laboratoires se sont pas
précipités pour revoir à la baisse leur
leur leurs données d'efficacité.
Quand le ministre de la santé qui il
fait ils font du business, ils font de
l'argent et ça c'est un problème le le
les les deux ministres de la santé
c'estàdire Agnèin, elle est tout
bibè Busin sur les vaccins, elle est
partie le 17 février donc elle y est.
OK. Verran, il tout bib. Oui, il fait de
la chirurgie esthétique, je crois pas.
Non, il est pas neurologue. Non, non,
mais maintenant il fait de la chirurgie
esthétique. Ah oui, non, mais ça ça paye
bien le le Et puis c'est ça permet de
soulager les gens quand ils ont des des
diffformités ou Ah bah s'ils ont trop
d'argent, ça soulage un peu leur
portefeuille. Ouais. Enfin, j'imagine
peut-être qu'il fait pour il fait de la
il fait de la chirurgie maxilofaciale
pour reconstruire les gens. Je pense il
le fait gratuitement. Non, je ne sais
pas. Non. Bon, c'est une hypothèse et
faut aller voir. Il fait pas grossir les
seins. Non.
Juste il était tout bible euh
Verrand. Quand on est tout bib, on a été
relu par ses pères, on a été jugé par
ses pères, on est devenu TBI de l'ordre
des médecins, on a un caducé, on a un
serment d'Hippocrate. Est-ce que TBIB
est politique ? Ça fait bon ménage
? Est-ce qu'on peut considérer que les
politiques ont le droit de mentir, de de
se comporter comme des voyou ? Ni les
uns ni les autres ne devrai se comporter
comme ça. Ni les uns ni les autres. Ni
les uns ni les autres. Mon sens à mon
sens c'est ça simplement.
Euh bah effectivement alors les tout bib
tout bib qui font de la politique on
sait plus trop où ils sont et comment à
quel niveau. Enfin quand ils font de la
politique ils sont pas
astreins au au secret médical ou un truc
comme ça. Ils sont pas dans une relation
avec un patient, ils sont en relation
avec un public. Pour moi, c'est pas
normal ce que les politiques nous
mentent. Mais faut habiter, faut bien
reconnaître que c'est quand même
fréquent.
Euh maintenant, si le médecin se
comportait de la même manière, il y
aurait un problème dans la relation
entre le médecin et le malade. Et ces
confrères, quand un confrère voit un
autre confrère raconter des billes ves à
la
télé, est-ce que les confrères, ils
disent "Allou grand patron des
confrères, vous allez m'attraper
celui-là parce qu'il est en train de
faire passer les médecins pour des
débiles mentaux." Et ça risque de nous
créer des problèmes auprès de nos
patients. Il risque d'être défiant. Il
risque de plus vouloir se vacciner. Il
risque de de nous envoyer péter. Il
risque de se tourner vers le sein de
nouveaux charlatan qui avec des petits
jus de fruits font repousser les
oreilles, font font marcher les
téraplégiques et gens passé des
meilleurs. C'est que moi qui parle. Non,
je pose une question. Ah, c'était une
question. Est-ce que les académies de
médecine, les conseil de l'ordre qui
voit un ministre de la santé qui est
tout bib sa porte-parole raconter
n'importe
nawak, est-ce que l'académie de
médecine, le conseil de
l'ordre, ils ont pas un petit peu une
responsabilité concernant la défiance
que le public un certain public a et
qu'on a pratiquement définitivement
perdu pour jamais vu le conseil de
l'ordre rappeler à l'ordre le ministre
de la santé en lui disant "Tu racontes
de la merde ?" Oui, j'ai jamais vu ça.
C'est dommage, non ? C'est qu'on paye sa
cotisation pour avoir un CADUC et que il
servent à rien. C'est peut-être que je
veux pas dire mais non mais non
là je suis tenu par la la comment on
appelle ça ? C'est un truc, c'est la la
la confraternité. Voilà. Donc je vais
rester confraternelle et faire un joker
sur le les relations entre savoir si le
conseil de l'ordre doit vilipand les
ministres quand ils disent des choses
quand ils sont tout bib bah normalement
quand il parlent en tant que ministre
ils parlent en tant que ministre ils
sont pas dans une relation de soin avec
un patient
pas mal comme
joker le mouvement antivax qui qu'on a à
l'heure actuelle et qui est mondialisé
parce que comme ils ont raconté à peu
près le même type de connerie un peu
partout dans le monde, ça a créé que
c'est pas lié qu'aux conneries enfin il
y a des il y a le mouvement antivax est
au croisement de
courants naturaliste d'un côté
religieux.
Il y a il y a vraiment tous ces éléments
et puis une contestation effectivement
plus systématique, plus éventuellement
plus rigoureuse de du comportement de
des labos qui font les vaccins. Tout est
possible mais et puis il y a cette idée
de de liberté a cette opposition entre
la liberté des individus et la
protection de la communauté.
Et ça, c'est pas moi qui vais arbitrer
ce genre de chos parce que selon les
circonstances euh ben des fois il faut
protéger la communauté, des fois il faut
protéger la liberté des individus. C'est
extrêmement
politique et je veux pas me positionner
dans ça. Moi, c'est je veux expliquer ce
qui se passe, donner un
éclairage, rappeler que ça a existé.
Après, chacun fait ce qu'il en en fait
son miel avec et essaie de comprendre ce
qui s'est passé. Euh je veux pas rentrer
dans ce rôle d'arbitrer entre les vac,
les provax, les antivax. Euh dans
certains cas, et je pense que c'est
important de le dire aussi quand un
vaccin n'est pas efficace ou très peu
efficace. C'est des campagnes de
vaccination chez les gamins avec le
vaccin contre le choléra, chez les
enfants de moins de 5 ans alors que on
n'a pas
démontré. Euh moi je préfère dire il
faut pas le faire mais c'est parce que
c'est basé sur un résultat d'efficacité.
Après sur les choix qu'on a à faire
quand on est en situation d'épidémie et
que la société est bloquée par
l'épidémie commence on se dépatouille
avec le passe ou pas le passe,
l'obligation pas
l'obligation et autres stratégies c'est
de de du ressort du politique. La seule
chose que je veux dire, c'est
que au moins que ce soit dit avec la
plus avec les éléments les plus sincères
possibles. Et c'est pour ça des masques,
pas des masques, c'était beaucoup plus
facile à expliquer de que quand on fait
quelque chose, je pense qu'on on doit
mériter la confiance des personnes pour
lesquelles on prend des décisions
politiques, même si ces décisions vont
contre leur avis, parce que jamais tout
le monde sera d'accord.
Et là dans le l'arbitrage, dans cette
histoire, au moment où il y avait le
Covid, l'arbitrage était entre
finalement protéger les personnes les
plus âgées, les plus à risque et c'était
très compliqué de les de les protéger
sans envisager de vacciner les personnes
qui étaient susceptibles de rentrer en
contact avec. Et donc ça sous-entendait
de vacciner des personnes, par exemple
des infirmiers, des soignants qui
pouvaient avoir des contacts avec des
personnes âgées qui pouvaient être
porteurs du virus et pas vacciné. Donc
ça c'était un problème mais c'est un
arbitrage, c'est un choix parce que d'un
côté effectivement c'est la liberté de
l'infirmière ou de l'infirmier qui veut
pas se vacciner et ça s'entend très
bien. Et puis c'est la sécurité de la
personne âgée qui ne n'est pas forcément
d'accord pour attraper qu' a peur
d'attraper le virus. Les deux existent
et alors là après c'est un choix de
société, c'est un choix euh politique.
C'est pas au médecin de faire ce choix à
la place des politiques dans un contexte
de crise comme ça. On peut juste
l'éclairer par des données d'efficacité
et euh conseiller de d'être le plus
loyal, le plus franc possible vis-à-vis
des personnes. Faut faire un rappel pour
la variole.
Pour l'instant non, mais euh il faudrait
quand même s'occuper très
sérieusement de du
MPOX. C'est la la comment ça s'appelle ?
C'est le c'était avant le monkex. L'erp
du singe. Non, c'est la variole du
singe. Vari du singe. Exact. Mais c'est
pas la variole du singe en fait. Le
point de départ c'est les rongeurs. Et
c'est le même point de départ finalement
à très peu de choses près que la variole
il y a 3500 ans. On est en Afrique,
c'était un virus de gerb de rongeur qui
est passé à l'homme, qui est passé au
dromadaire. Ça fait deux lignées
différentes. Et c'est comme ça qu'on a
eu le le la variole et puis on l'a
éradiqué. Et puis maintenant comme il y
a plus de vari de campagne de
vaccination contre la variole et bien le
le monkeepox qui est devenu lex il y a
juste changer le nom maintenant et
commence à à diffuser avec des dizaines
de milliers de cas l'année dernière en
République démocratique du Congo et
comme c'est ça a des variations
saisonnières je pense que il ça va
encore réaugmenter et ça va avoir une
transmission c'est ce qu'on on a vu
l'année dernière une transmission
interhumaine. Le virus est en train de
s'adapter à l'homme et on ne met pas
assez de moyens. Et là pour le coup euh
oui, il faut vacciner et vacciner là où
il y a le les cas. Donc il faudrait on
peut le vaccin contre la variole a une
part d'efficacité contre ce Mpox parce
que les virus sont proches. Sinon ben on
va laisser diffuser un virus comme ça
jusqu'à ce qu'il soit pratiquement pas
gérable et à ce moment-là on aura plus
qu'à essayer de se protéger. plus ou
moins bien en Europe, dans les pays
riches en disant "Bah tant pis pour les
pour les autres". C'est un vrai
problème, une stratégie qui est pas du
tout prise au sérieux. Enfin, la
problématique bien sûr, il y a des gens
à l'OMS qui s'alarment mais en réalité
les moyens sont pas là pour arrêter ce
qui est un début de pandémie.
Qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait faire ? Euh
vacciner, isoler, aider les pays qui
parce que maintenant c'est plusieurs
pays en Afrique centrale les pays qui
sont touchés par ce MPOX et ne pas
attendre simplement que ça vienne faire
comme en 2022 une épidémie chez les
patients homosexuels des pays riches.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe quand le
financement USID a été diminué ou arrêté
sur bah les organismes ou les
associations médicales ? Ça veut dire
moins de traitement contre la
tuberculose. Donc il va y avoir plus de
cas, plus de résistance et plus de
problèmes de tuberculose à
l'importation. Après ça veut dire moins
de moyens pour le paludisme. Et là on
voit aussi qu'on a plus de cas de
paludisme importé. Ça veut dire moins de
moyens pour la variole et cetera. Et
donc une euh comme on est nombreux comme
euh les conditions de vie de dans les
villes les bidonvillees et cetera sont
assez lamentables, il va y avoir une
réactivation, ça donne plus de chance
aux maladies
infectieuses. C'est peut-être voulu. Moi
je me pose la question, je me dis que
c'est peut-être vou conspirationniste.
En tout cas, je peux pas je peux pas
imaginer une seconde que ceux qui
prennent cette décision n'ont pas
l'information que euh ces moyens-là
servent à diminuer l'impact des maladies
infectieuses. Donc s'il les coupe et
s'il coupe la
surveillance, ils le savent. Ils savent
pourquoi ils le font. Après, qu'est-ce
qu'il cherche par là ? Faire des
économies, ça marche pas parce que au
bout d'un moment, ça va revenir en
boomerang. Donc, ils peuvent pas ne pas
savoir que il faut de l'argent pour
traiter la tuberculose, pour diminuer le
paludisme, pour lutter contre le MOX.
Ils peuvent pas ne pas le savoir. Ils
sont au courant. Donc s'ils le font, ils
le font en connaissance de cause. Faut
pas prendre les gens pour des débiles,
même quand ils ont des parole un peu à
l'emporte pièce comme le président des
des États-Unis. Il est quand même un peu
informé ou pas ?
Non ou pas ? Non non. Oui. Le rasoir de
cam la théorie la plus simple et souvent
la meilleure. Il est juste peut-être pas
informé. Il coupe il coupe au cô
entrepreneur. Pas une démonstration.
Non, je suis d'accord. C'est pas
forcément la cellule la théorie la plus
simple. Est-ce que pour le Covid-19, on
nous a pris pour des débiles mentaux, on
nous a infantilisé ? À certains moments,
on en a
l'impression. On revient toujours les
mêmes histoires, les masques, les trucs,
le café assis, pas assis. Oui, on a
traité tous les sujets, c'est déjà pas
mal. Pas tous. Est-ce qu'il y a un sujet
qu'on a oublié ? Est-ce que je sais pas,
j'ai répondu aux questions mais je sais
pas si on avait
sur le chat. Je vais vous poser une
devinette pendant que je vais je vais
chercher je vais chercher quelques
questions sur le chat.
Est-ce que vous savez pourquoi pendant
les épidémies de
peste les gens qui travaillaient au
contact des chevaux étaient peu ou pas
touchés
? que j'ai Non non non mais ce que j'ai
entendu dire c'est que les puces pas le
le l'odeur des chevaux
mais donc peut-être que le chevalier
rose qui a est combattu la peste sur la
place de la tourette à Marseille, il
était à cheval, on le voit dans sur les
peintures. Peut-être que ça l'a
protégeé. Mais en tout cas, c'est ce qui
est dit, c'est que les les puces
n'aiment pas le le cheval.
les puces dur. Question internet de Gaë
: l'espace l'espace est devenu un
nouveau laboratoire pour la biologie
expérimentale. Pensez-vous que nous
prenons suffisamment au sérieux les
risques potentiels liés à la
dissémination de micro-organismes
modifiés ou sélectionnés en orbite ?
Franchement, c'est euh d'aller
les micro-organismes normes, tu vois pas
trop à quoi ça peut servir, mais c'est
pas là qu'on va les attraper. Euh les
mêmes, je pense que on peut les attraper
sur la terre. Euh je suis pas très au
courant des manibes qui sont faites euh
en orbite ou pas. Euh l'important c'est
de manipuler les virus, les bactéries et
ça c'est ça nous met en danger.
Oui. Question internet qui est archi
longue donc je vais quand même essayer
de la de la
poser. Je m'interroge sur les
discussions récentes autour du
développement d'armes biologiques, en
particulier dans les SN tank spécialisés
en biosécurité et au sein des
départements de défense américain. Il
soulligne la possibilité d'un groupe
malveillant. utilise des outils de
biologie moléculaire pour recréer ou
modifier un virus existant ou même
inventer un virus entièrement nouveau.
Principa accessibilité croissante des
outils des kits douit sur self
rendre de la biologie moléculaire plus
accessible. On peut aussi commander du
matériel de laboratoire sur les
plateformes comme Alibaba ou via les
sites de reconditionnement.
Facilité d'accès au savoir. De point,
les protocoles de biologie moléculaire
sont disponibles en ligne via des
moteurs de recherche ou des spécialistes
spécialisés ou des formes spécialisées.
Convergence, intelligence artificielle
et biologie. De point des modèles
d'intelligence artificielle sont
désormais capables de générer de
nouvelles séquences protéiques,
potentiellement toxiques ou de nouvelles
séquences ADN, voire par exemple EVO. 02
Evo 2 pardon. Contexte historique dès la
seconde guerre mondiale, plusieurs
programmes de bioarmes ont existé.
Biopréparate en URSS, lâché de
l'entraquex sur des côtes américaines.
Programme enfin pas sur les côtes
américaines mais déjà localement par un
accident. Oui. Programme en ancienne
rodésie. Horrible ça. Horrible.
D'ailleurs Bob Cohen qui connaît très
bien la Rodésie m'en a longtemps parlé.
Aujourd'hui, les mêmes risques refont
surface avec des technologies plus
puissantes et plus accessibles. Ma
question déjà euh je suis d'accord avec
le la présentation de du problème. Ce
problème existe, on le connaît, c'est un
killer, c'est un killer de la
communauté. Sur Twitter, on le voit des
débarqués. Ce qu'il dit est exact.
Donc sa question. En tant qu'ancien
scientifique et désormais professionnel
travaillant sur ces sujets, je suis
souvent prise pris entre des discours
très alarmistes entre parenthèses même
de la part de scientifiques reconnus,
fermez la parenthèse et des et des
positions excessivement
techno-optimistes. Question : quel est
votre point de vue sur ces débats ?
Comment évaluer la gravité réelle du
risque face à de nouvelles à ces
nouveaux outils ? Question numéro 2, le
penser critique sans sombrer dans la
peur ni l'angélisme technologique.
effectivement ce qui a été dit la
démocratisation, c'est un mot qui est
pas tout à fait adapté mais on comprend
le sens de la biologie moléculaire de la
de le la possibilité effectivement de se
procurer les séquences ADN, de les
assembler non pas quand même dans un
garage mais quand même dans
des
organisations qui peuvent être déjà
moins moins puissante que simplement les
très grandes puissances comme avant.
Donc ça ça existe la possibilité de
modifier de multiplier un germe et de le
diffuser. C'est tout à fait envisageable
et je suis vraiment inquiet de cette
possibilité. Et chaque fois que un
article est publié disant on a
ressuscité tel ou tel type de virus où
on a adapté tel ou tel virus à telle ou
telle circonstan gains de fonction euh
tout ça est extrêmement inquiétant non
seulement au titre des accidents de
laboratoire mais au titre de la
malveillance.
Donc je crois que l'homme est tout à
fait capable de créer des germes
dangereux pour l'homme et ces programmes
effectivement qui ont été cités et
d'autres comme le l'unité 731 pour entre
le Japon et la et la Chine, les Japonais
qui ont infecté des territoires chinois.
Euh ça ça existe, ça a existé, ça
existera. Et donc plus le les virus sont
manipulables, plus on sait comment faire
un fléo pour l'humanité, plus on a de
chance que ça arrive, enfin de chance de
risque que ça arrive. Donc je fais, on
va dire, je fais partie des
pessimistes. Ça c'était la première
question. La deuxième c'était alors la
deuxième c'est le
penser
critiquement sans sombrer dans la peur
ni l'angélisme technologique. Bah il
s'agit pas de sombrer ni dans la peur ni
dans le dans le dans
l'angélisme. Alors il s'agit de pointer
un risque qui existe et euh au moins
qu'on soit au courant. et deuxièmement
de souhaiter que même si ça annile pas
le risque qu'il y ait euh des mesures
prises comme on prend des mesures pour
limiter la prolifération nucléaire par
exemple.
Or, à la fois, c'est plus facile de
faire un
germe potentiellement pandémique que de
faire une bombe
atomique. Il y a moins besoin de de
moyens et pourtant le nucléaire
prolifère progressivement.
Donc c'est plus facile de faire un germe
potentiellement pandémique et
c'est pourtant on surveille beaucoup
moins ces ces activités qu'on surveille
le nucléaire. Il y a quelque chose
d'incohérent dans cette dans cette
manière de faire. Surveiller ce qui se
passe dans les laboratoires me
paraîtrait quelque chose de la moindre
des choses. Avoir une sorte de boîte
noire dans les laboratoires, mais ça ne
suffit pas. avoir un contrôle de tous
les protocoles qui sont faits dès lors
que il y a un risque de de faire quelque
chose d'un accident. Ne pas publier
tout, ne pas mettre à disposition la
recette pour faire tel ou tel virus. Je
pense que ce serait raisonnable. Il y a
quand même un certain nombre de mesures
à prendre qui me paraissent totalement
raisonnables. Je pense que il y a parmi
nos confrères
chercheurs de temps en temps des
personnes qui n'ont pas la conscience du
risque que ça peut
représenter. Donc c'est pour ça qu'il
faut rappeler sans alarmer qui que ce
soit mais rappeler tous les accidents
qui ont déjà eu lieu, y compris avec des
diffusions à l'échelle planétaire comme
la grippe de 1977. Et c'est pour ça
qu'il faudrait avoir fait correctement
l'investigation de cette pandémie de
Covid qui n'a toujours pas été
investigué de manière satisfaisante.
Bon, si on parlait un peu fungicide,
question internet.
Le réchauffement climatique entraîne une
hausse de l'humidité favorable au
développement des champignons. Y a-t-il
un risque que les prochaines épidémie ne
soient pas causé par un virus ou une
bactérie, mais plutôt par un champignon
? Si cela advenait, comment traiter une
telle épidémie entre parenthèses vaccin
antibiotique inefficace ? Fermer la
parenthèse. Alors les champignons, alors
c'est une heureusement c'est une autre
casquette parce que c'est pas facile
mais comme je suis prof de parasitologie
et de mycologie médicale euh j'ai quand
même quelques moyens de m'en sortir.
Première chose donc je vais
répondre sinon j'aurais pas répondu,
j'aurais fait de joker. Première chose,
on a on estime à peu près un million de
morts les infections liées aux
champignons dans le monde chaque année.
Donc c'est pas totalement anodin les
champignons. Deuxièmement, il y a des
problématiques liées au fongicides et au
fond dans
l'agriculture. on s'inquiète dans une
certaine certaines maladies sont lié à
des champignons qui s'appellent les
aspergilus d'avoir des aspergilus
résistants et ça c'est lié beaucoup à
l'horticulture en
Hollande et donc ça fait des souches
d'aspergilus parce que les champignons
sont souvent des phytopathogènes au
départ qui peu des souches d'aspergilus
qui peuvent être responsables et puis il
peut y avoir effectivement en tout cas
il y a dans le monde animal, il y a eu
des euh des épidémies liées à des
champignons qui peuvent détruire des
populations animales. Donc ça existe. Et
il y a j'ai parlé de Peter d'Azac qui
s'est rendu célèbre par des travaux au
début sur des champignons qui
détruisaient les
Batraciens. Donc il y a il y a il y a
des problématiques liées au au aux
champignons et aux animaux. Et
évidemment chez l'homme, je dis un
million de morts par an estimé par
l'OMS. Donc ça existe traitement. Ben
les traitements c'est les antifongiques
mais ces antifongiques qui sont utilisés
dans l'agriculture et donc on est en
train de cer la branche sur lequel on
est assis. C'est-à-dire que à force de
d'élever des champignons résistants,
enfin évidemment ça crée des
résistances, et bien on a une
répercussion en pathologie vétérinaire
ou humaine, ce qui est la même chose
d'ailleurs avec les antibiotiques
utilisés dans l'agriculture.
Question internet, peut-on dire que les
épidémies créent des zones grises de
gouvernance où les ONG ou les puissances
étrangères supplantent les États ?
Est-ce que l'histoire de grande épidémie
est racontée par ceux qui les vivent ?
ou par ceux qui les gèrent. On va
commencer par par qui sont construits
les récits qui restent. Alors, on
commence par la première question. Les
deux questions sont donc rôle des ONG,
rôle des interventions
extérieures,
incontestable et euh ONG ou
fondation et avec des choix qui sont pas
forcément dans l'intérêt des
populations qui sont victimes de ces
épidémies. Alors, on est sur le le
terrain que je connais mieux, c'est les
épidémies de choléra. les épidémies de
choléra, on peut intervenir en agissant
d'abord sur l'accès à l'eau et à et
l'assainissement, mais ça n'intéresse
pas beaucoup les bailleurs de fond et
les ONG sur ces trucs, il y en a mais
c'est quand même très limite et puis ça
c'est coûteux. On peut intervenir en
aidant les ministères de la santé à
organiser la riposte et à investiguer et
à intervenir très rapidement sur les
épidémies de choléra. Et ça ben les ONG
n'aiment pas tellement. Euh moi, je me
suis un peu disputé quand j'étais à
médecin du monde. Je voulais qu'il y ait
des choses qui se fassent dans le temps
et c'était compliqué à obtenir. Et puis
on peut faire comme finalement ce qui
est mis en avant. Si vous avez un jour
une inondation quelque part en Afrique,
au Mozambique ou ailleurs, on va vous
dire "Ou là là, il y a un risque de
choléra. On va vous envoyer 1 million de
vaccins, il va y avoir une campagne de
vaccination, ça va se faire 15 jours, 3
semaines après l'inondation. On va vous
dire que c'est un succès extraordinaire.
8 jours après, tout le monde a a plié
bagage, la campagne est faite, le
problème est pas réglé et ça c'est euh
très valorisant pour les fondations et
pour les ONG, y compris MSF. Un petit
coup de patte à mes MSF. J'apprécie
énormément cette cette organisation,
mais quand ils partent comme ça faire
des campagnes de vaccination qui
reviennent et que finalement euh ils ont
déserté le terrain après pour euh euh
agir où on il faudrait agir sur le long
terme et aider à maintenir une vigilance
sur les épidémies dans ces dans ces
endroits-là, et bien c'est pas fait. Et
en plus, ils se font embobiner parce que
ils utilisent des vaccins qui sont pas
forcément efficaces sur la population
qui qu'ils vaccinent. par exemple des
vaccins anticolé chez des enfants de
moins de 5 ans. Donc il y a un problème
et le problème c'est effectivement parce
que c'est plus photogénique, c'est plus
ça va donner lieu à des reportages qui
vont mieux parler à la population des
donateurs, c'est il y a des choix qui
sont faits en particulier par la
fondation Gates de d'être vraiment sur
une réponse vaccinale là où on pourrait
avoir une réponse accès à l'eau,
détection rapide des épidémies et plein
d'autres
interventions. La deuxième partie de la
question, j'ai pas répondu parce que je
prends partie par partie. La deuxième
partie, je me souviens plus. Alors les
récit Oui, c'est très important. Et ben,
c'est lié. C'est lié parce que certains
fois ça donne des récits. Vas-y. Est-ce
que Est-ce que l'histoire des grandes
épidémies est racontée par ceux qui les
vivent ou par ceux qui les gèrent ? Par
construits les récits qui restent.
Ils sont
construits beaucoup par ce qui les
gèrent. Euh s'il y a une implication
politique, ça va être important.
Donc effectivement euh c'est d'abord les
dirigeants qui ont l'accès à la mémoire
historique. Donc ça maintenant on a les
moyens sur les épidémies un peu plus
récentes d'aller voir des témoignages
divergents et ensuite le la connaissance
des épidémies et la connaissance des de
la situation permet de
corriger ça et de faire en sorte que des
récits plus objectifs émergent derrière.
Et de toute
façon, chaque celui qui va prendre la
parole sur une
épidémie a souvent des intérêt à
défendre. Il parle pas de rien et c'est
jamais une parole totalement
neutre. La réponse est donnée. Oui.
Alors,
question internet. Ce virus SARSCOV 2
probablement créé par l'homme et propagé
à la suite d'une fuite de laboratoire a
entraîner la première épidémie mondiale
d'origine humaine. Les
laboratoires on y a répondu. On a la
grippe on a la grippe de
1977. Ce serait la deuxème.
Les laboratoires P3 et P4 sont-ils
désormais mieux contrôlés ou ont-ils
durci leur procédures pour éviter de
nouvelles fuites ? Point
d'interrogation. Par ailleurs, le
Covid-19 pourrait-elle inspirer
certaines puissances à développer de
nouvelles armes de dissuasion ? Alors
euh je rappelle le P4 est pas dans en
cause puisque les manipes n'étaient pas
dans le P4. On reprochait même de pas
faire de P3 et c'était souvent en P2.
Donc ça c'est un problème et peut-être
une des raisons pour lesquelles on pense
que la fuite d'un laboratoire est encore
plus probable parce que c'est le le
contexte dans lequel c'est fait. Ce
contexte, je l'invente pas, il est
expliqué dans les publications qui
précédaient la pandémie sur des types de
recherches qui avaient été fait dans les
mêmes laboratoires. Donc sur le niveau
de de sécurité, c'était largement
suffisant. Et après la fin de la
question, je réponds qu'à des morceaux
de questions parce que la fin de la
question, est-ce que ça va inspirer des
puissances pour faire des armes de
dissuasion massive ? Euh oui, je pense
que ça doit inspirer des puissances euh
pour en tout cas euh
réussir à enfumer la
population sur euh s'il se passe quelque
chose. On arrivera toujours à construire
et ça c'est quand même une belle
découverte. On peut construire des
discours pour que les gens s'y perdent
au moins pendant un certain
temps. Euh et c'est quand même ce qui
s'est passé avec toutes les moyens
modernes de la de la science, on a
réussi à enfumer la
population. Donc ça, moi je trouve que
c'est très
inspirant et inquiétant d'ailleurs.
Ouais. Mais je vais revenir à mon côté
ordre des médecins. Comment on peut
enfumer l'ordre des médecins ? Comment
on peut enfumer les vieux tout bib ?
Mais c'est pas leur spécialité les
épidémies.
Question internet. Professeur Pierou,
depuis peu, l'OMS a désormais un pouvoir
supranational en ayant la possibilité de
placer en quarantaine des pays sans
avoir besoin de l'Aval. Quel est votre
avis sur la question ? Merci.
Question de Doc Doc, méfiez-vous, c'est
peut-être un confrère. Oui oui, mais
c'est peut-être un confrère mais j'avais
pas l'impression que l'OMS avait la
capacité par exemple de mettre en
quarantaine un pays comme la Chine ou ça
dépendra de la la taille du pays mais je
j'ai pas l'impression que l'OMS c'est la
moindre intention de mettre en
quarantaine en quarantaine le moindre
pays. Non, ça c'est
alors c'est ce qui est dans la question
me surprend.
sourcewo.intinint international. Les
Étatsmembres approuvent l'accord de
l'OMS sur les pandémies au sein des
commissions de l'Assemblée nationale de
la santé, ouvrant ainsi la voie à son
adoption
formelle. L'accord historique sera
examiné par l'adoption mardi en séance
plinière de l'Assemblée le 19 mai 2025.
Le papier qui date de 19 mai 2025. Bon,
je vais pas lire tout le papier. Oui.
Euh mais des résolutions de l'OMS, il y
en a. Et effectivement, il y a l'OMS
voudrait limiter le risque de pandémie,
mais n'ont pas un pouvoir extraordinaire
pour ça et ils ne vont pas très loin
dans ce domaine.
Euh, je suis en train de regarder une
longue longue question, donc il faut que
je la lise parce que c'est des sujets
relativement chaud patate. Oui, mais
après les auditeurs peut-être en ont
assez. Non, il est crevé, il est crevé
le professeur. Non, ça va. Mais euh
question internet. Bonjour, je travaille
à l'hôpital de la Timon à Marseille. Ça
vous intéresse ou on passe à une autre
question ? Question : Je prends, je
connais bien. Alors euh j'espère que
c'est un vrai une vraie personne qui
travaille vraiment à la Timone parce que
j'ai pas encore fini de lire la
question. Donc on va lire la lire
ensemble. Bonjour, je travaille à
l'hôpital de la Timone à Marseille. Je
vais régulièrement voir des patients à
l'iU entre parenthèses qui se situent
exactement sur le même site. Ferm la
parenthèse. Est-ce que c'est vrai ?
C'est pas vrai ? Oui, c'est à côté.
D'accord. L'Hu a fait un travail
impressionnant pendant toute la
pandémie. Ils ont reçu tous les patients
qui se sont présentés, les ont exploré
et soignés entre parenthèses sans
obligation d'hydrochloro ou ça doit être
hydrochloroxyquine. Malgré ce qui a été
dit. Fermer la parenthèse. J'ai un
sentiment amè sur l'image qui a été
renvoyée par les médias envers le
personnel admirable de
l'IHU et de la PHM en général. J'ai
moi-même travaillé sans masque auprès de
patients dès le premier jour de
confinement alors que des médecins
généralistes refusaient de voir des
patients. L'hôpital a accueilli vecteur
de contamination. Au secours ! L'hôpital
a accueilli des milliers de malades. Le
bâtiment de l'ashu est impeccable et
extrêmement bien pensé. Sans parler de
Didi Raou, votre invité pense-t-il qu'il
faut créer davantage d'HU en France pour
pouvoir réagir correctement pendant les
autres pandémies à venir pour
interrogation et un soignant qui a pas
de de de masque, c'est pas cool quand
même, non ?
Je sais pas à quel moment, dans quelles
circonstances.
un que le l'IHU est accueilli beaucoup
de malades, c'est exact ça ne fait pas
de la bon il y a eu des discussions sur
le fait que certains de ces malades ont
dû payer et payer relativement cher des
hôpitaux de jour et là il y a eu des
discussions et j'ai pas le détail, je
sais pas où jusqu'où c'est arrivé. Euh
la deuxième chose, ça fait pas pour ça
que c'est pas pour ça que la
l'hydroxychloroine était efficace ou pas
efficace. Euh le fait d'accueillir les
malades, c'était son rôle, il fallait le
faire. Il y a à l'achu des gens que je
connais bien, il y a des amis, je les
salue, je les embrasse. Euh donc euh il
sait pas euh je vois pas l'achu comme un
repère de gangster. Euh il y a des gens
avec qui je suis d'accord, d'autres avec
qui je suis pas d'accord et finalement
c'est c'est la vie, c'est comme ça. Donc
oui, ils ont pris en charge des malades.
Oui, ils ont fait leur job. Euh c'est
pas pour ça que l'hydroxychloroine était
un médicament efficace. Malheureusement,
ça n'était pas un médicament efficace
contre le Covid. Question internet.
Est-ce que les grandes épidémies
laissent des traces dans nos corps qui
vont au-delà de la maladie elle-même
jusque dans l'expression de nos gênes
? Oui, c'est un peu compliqué mais oui,
on a démontré que alors des l'exemple il
y a des exemples sur la peste, il y a
des gènes enfin des modifications
génétiques qui sont liées à la peste.
Mais l'exemple plus connu, c'est quand
même le paludisme où on a des gènes qui
ont été inactivés qui permettent plus au
à certaines formes de paludisme à
infecter certaines populations en
Afrique noire. Euh je pense au au
plasmonium vivax, enfin c'est un peu
trop technique, mais en tout cas peut y
avoir des modifications génétiques
jusqu'à même favoriser un certain nombre
de maladies constitutionnelles du sang
euh qui sont favorisées par la pression
du paludisme. Sachant que un sang une
hémoglobine pas tout à fait normale et
pas adapté pour le plasmodium, la gent
du paludisme. Donc c'est un équilibre
finalement des gens qui
sont avec des malformations
constitutionnelles du sang peuvent être
protégé contre le paludisme. Et donc on
a ces ces maladies comme la
drépanocytose ou la talémie. Oui, le les
maladies influencent sur notre génome et
globalement euh au bout d'un certain
temps, on devient plus résistant
génération après génération plus
résistant qu'un cer sur un certain
nombre de pathogènes.
C'est toujours OK. Les tests nous
question internet. Quit de l'immunité
collective qui nous a été vendu avec la
vaccination pour tous. Autre
question. A-t-il déjà entendu parler de
l'intelligence ? Tu fais tu fais deux
questions à la fois. Je peux pas
répondre. D'accord. Donc l'immunité
collective, ben le problème c'est de la
la durabilité de cette immunité. Elle
existe évidemment mais elle est pas
forcément durable surtout quand il y a
une modification du virus qui intervient
rapidement. Elle reste quand même sur
les formes les plus graves. On voit que
les vagues épidémiques de Covid au fil
du temps font de moins en moins
d'hospitalisation. C'est déjà ça.
Question internet de Totoro. Merci de
loin. Le Sinkerview le plus flippant.
Question : "A-t-il" Non, ils sont
passionnés, hein. A-t-il entendu parler
de l'intelligence artificielle
anthropique Claude qui a récemment mené
des ingénieurs dans un test ? Si
comment qui comment
? Ouais. Menacé pardon des ingénieurs
dans un test. Si oui, quel est-ce moi
aussi j'ai la vu qui baisse. Qu'est-ce
que cela lui inspire ? Donc j'ai pas
entendu parler de ça. OK. Quelle est
question internet ? Quel est l'état de
nos stocks actuels de médicaments et de
matériel médical en cas d'épidémie pour
interrogation ? On peut tenir combien de
temps en cas de super virus,
superbactéries ? Alors le les stocks, je
suis pas en charge de ça. Je suis juste
quelqu'un qui réfléchit sur les
épidémies donc dans l'histoire et qui
est vécu sur un certain nombre
d'épidémies. Je ne sais pas où on en est
des stocks. On a eu des très mauvaises
surprises, rappelons-le, au début de du
Covid. Donc euh c'est quelque chose
qu'il faudrait vérifier. Effectivement,
vous avez des problèmes aussi pour les
analyses en terme de de petit tube, de
moyen tube, de Oui, oui, oui, même des
les les côes pour la sérologie et
cetera, on consommé et c'est fait en
polypropylène et il y a eu un moment où
on avait plus de cône où il fallait
qu'on limite et et comme moi je
dirigeais un laboratoire, on était on
nous disait attention, on en aura plus.
C'est c'était fabriqué je pense en Chine
c'est que on était obligé de choisir
entre faire la scérologie de la vieille
et faire la scérologie du jeune.
Finalement c'est passé. Il y a pas on n'
pas eu à faire ce choix-là mais il y a
eu un moment où effectivement alors il y
a eu des ruptures pour les masques, mais
il y en a pas eu pour ces trucs là mais
il y a eu un moment les tubes aussi les
les tubes Falcon les Conendorf les
choses comme ça je donne les marques. On
narrivait plus for pas forcément à se
s'approvisionner. nous disait non pas
tout de suite, peut-être dans quelques
semaines vous les aurez. Et ça a suffi
quand on est médecin euh qu'on a qu'on a
fait serment d'Hippocrate,
Oui. Euh on se retrouve dans une
épidémie, une
pandémie et on se retrouve à trier des
patients. Est-ce qu'on les trie en
fonction de leur heure d'arrivée, de
leur âge, de leur comorbidité ? Comment
ça se passe normalement ?
Ça existe, on peut être amené à trier en
contexte de crise, contexte de guerre et
en contexte d'épidémie. Et pour ce qui
est, ça dépend de la pathologie, mais
par exemple le Covid, ça peut être en
fonction de l'âge. Le passage en
réanimation peut être considéré
comme non faisable à certains moments
pour selon les tr tranches d'âge. Alors
déjà, c'est jamais bon de mettre
quelqu'un de 80 ans en réanimation.
Donc ça peut être même en dehors de
toute crise, ça peut être quelque chose
qu'on va discuter. Est-ce qu'on peut le
faire ou pas ? Mais en période de rush
épidémique, peut-être que cet âge a pu
être abaissé. Oui. Mettre quelqu'un de
80 ans en réa, c'est considéré comme de
l'acharnement thérapeutique ou bah ça
dépend ça dépend la cause, ça dépend
comment, ça dépend pourquoi, ça dépend
le terrain, ça se discute mais ça peut
être un critère.
Mais là c'est normalement c'est dans
l'intérêt du patient. Enfin c'est pas la
peine non plus de faire effectivement de
l'acharnement. Mais en période
d'épidémie bah cette cet âge peut
baisser. Oui. Là récemment euh on a vu
la loi euthanasie.
Je suis pas dans non
j'ai aucune connaissance particulière
apporter à ce à ça. Je ne pense pas que
ce soit à moi de commenter ça.
C'est un deuxième joker à moitié. Non.
Oh ben je fais ce que je veux. J'en ai
autant que je veux.
Euh on a fait le tour, il y a encore
plein de questions. On a on a on a fait
une petite dernière.
Al pourquoi commander 10 doses de vaccin
Covid avec madame Vorerleen ? C'est
parce qu'ils avaient très très peur. Il
fallait faire plein de booster, plein de
rappels et que ils étaient très
inquiets. J'étais pas là avec elle. Je
sais pas de quoi il par vous avez pas lu
les SMS. Non, c'est dommage. Euh, on
arrive à la fin de notre interview.
Est-ce que vous avez Comment j'ai pas
vu. Est-ce que vous avez trois livres à
conseiller à notre communauté, mis à
part le vôtre que vous allez montrer euh
Ah oui, on l'a pas montré. Allez, on le
montre. Alle on va faire quelque chose
d'autre. Tu as besoin de lunettes pour
lire ou tu veux que je lise à ta place ?
Ah bah tu vas lire parce que moi je Oui.
Ah tu déconnes Ah si, vas-y si tu veux.
Alors montre-le, montre-le, montre-le.
Donc moi, j'ai lu une partie, je me suis
régalé. C'est euh je le conseille Non
mais montre-le à la caméra, t'inquiète
pas. Tu veux que je fasse la lecture
encore ? Bah si tu veux en faire quelque
chose. Mais mais non, je veux je veux
surtout que tu le montres à la à la
caméra. Sois pas timide comme
ça. Voilà. essaie de me faire un plan
sur ses yeux en même temps que le le
livre, ce bien. Voilà. Magnifique. Bon,
euh nous, on a lu une partie, c'est
meilleur qu'un documentaire rarteté, ça
fait voyager, ça apprend plein de trucs.
Bon, là, tu peux le reposer. Euh, il y a
plein d'anecdotes. Ah, et si moi j'ai
une question personnelle, l'espèce de
fièvre hémorragique dont tu parles en
Amérique du Sud, la coco chine. Le
cocolisli. Ouais, le cocolisli. On a eu
le fin mot de ce trucl ou pas ? Euh il y
a des Alors faut expliquer la c'est en
au Mexique de c'est la maladie qui a tué
le plus. C'est après la elle est elle
arrive après la variole et en fait euh
on descend de 20 millions d'habitants,
on descend à 2 millions euh et
essentiellement lié à cette maladie-là.
Euh et on l'a pas retrouvé ailleurs.
Elle s'est pas propagée ailleurs. Par
contre, elle a frappé le Mexique
jusqu'au 19e siècle, au début du 19e
siècle. On sait toujours pas vraiment ce
que c'est. Même si sur certains
squelettes, on a trouvé une salmonnelle,
donc un des virus qui une des bactéries
qui peut donner la fièvre typhoïde et
des choses comme ça. Mais ça ressemblait
pas, la description ressemblait pas à
celle de la fièvre typhoïde. Donc il y a
quand même des mystères. Il y a ça, il y
a la Suède aussi euh en Angleterre, des
maladies qui ont euh qui sont apparues,
qui ont disparu et qu'on dont on ne
connaît pas euh la cause et qu'on ne
reconnaît pas non plus comme euh dans
comme type de maladie.
Est-ce que tu as trois bouquins à
conseiller à notre communauté ? Il y a
euh ben la guerre des mondes pour le
pouvoir des microbes, c'est euh c'est un
un truc intéressant. Parce attaque
aussi, non ? Guerre des mondes.
peut-être un deuxième bouquin qui est
1493, c'est sur
une revoir l'histoire de la conquête de
des de l'Amérique enfin et des
États-Unis, mais du côté quand même
plutôt des Amérindiens et et c'est moins
moins à la gloire évidemment
de des cowboys et et des et des anglais
au départ. Et puis euh le troisème al
j'ai en fait t'embête sur un truc, c'est
pas un bouquin mais euh je je voudrais
pousser à euh voir ce que raconte
quelqu'un que j'ai écouté sur France
Inter qui s'appelle Arthur Keller et qui
parle de qui qui voit les problèmes
parce que finalement là on a vu par le
petit bout de la Norgnette. Bon, c'est
intéressant hein. C'est et c'est enfin
je veux pas dire que les épidémies c'est
pas c'est pas intéressant puis ça vient
compléter son discours d'une certaine
manière. Mais là, lui, il voit la
situation du monde de manière
systémique. La terre étant un système et
euh ça vient compléter par exemple les
interviews que tu as pu faire de
d'Aurore Stéphan, de Jean-Marc
Jeankovici. Enfin, donc il y a vraiment
euh des choses. Je conseille quand même
d'aller voir ce qu'il fait, même si la
manière dont il présente les choses est
un peu agaçante à certains moments. Euh
ce qu'il a à dire est très intéressant
au-delà de d'un ton petit peu
péremptoire. Est-ce que tu as un conseil
pour les jeunes générations ? Une une
bouteille à la mer, quelque chose
d'impérissable qui va rester sur
internet, qui ve qui veille sur ce qui
se passe parce
que il risque de pas aller très très
loin comme génération. Enfin là, on est
sur des périodes de temps finalement où
euh des
des personnes qui ont encore
officiellement 60 ou 80 ans à vivre euh
ont intérêt à se à prendre leur leur
avenir en main et faire en sorte que les
dirigeants nous amènent pas complètement
dans le mur et dans le chaos le plus
total. Il y a vraiment quelque chose à
faire de ce côté-là et j'ai l'impression
que les vieux nous on on n pas été très
bon pour ça mais on a même été très
mauvais.
Professeur Renault Pierou, merci. Merci.